okay recording great as chairman of the
house commerce and consumer affairs
committee i find the due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 and pursuant to executive
order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bills referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen
contemporariously in this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all the members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporariously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
of the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem assessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting access is meeting
the immediately will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each states their presence please
also state
whether there is anybody in the room
with you during this meeting
which is required on the right to know
law
all right keith yeah all right uh
representative hunt
i am here and i am all alone
representative
patusik
it's unusual okay you follow mute
representative osborne
representative amman president and alone
representative abramson
representative hamm here alone
representative de palma you're alone
representative greeson president alone
representative johnson
here in the llb
with max is max there
yeah he just bought it
representative terry i am uh
here and i'm alone in this room
representative bartlett
i'm here and alone in this room
representative abel
representative abel representative
herbert
um i'm here uh alone in this room
somebody else is working in another
office
representative van halton president
alone
representative fargo i'm here and i'm
representative weston here and alone
representative bill you here home alone
representative burroughs i'm here alone
in this room
representative mccleary uh here
currently alone
in this room all right
that is uh let's see 16 present mr shea
good uh all right so we will open up the
public hearing and senate bill 36 and
hear from the prime sponsor
senator french good morning mr chairman
good morning chairman hunt how are you
today
i'm just dandy hey good morning to the
entire commerce committee
for the record my name is harold french
senator
district seven and i'm here to present
to you today
senate bill 36 for your consideration
a very good bill at that this
is this is a recommendation
from the insurance department and this
bill
would remove the requirement that
applicants
applying for automobile coverage do not
have to
sign the statement of residency
it's an outdated requirement that
they're looking to
get rid of
that's it there's not much to it
um as you know most uh
most times when i apply for or
get new coverage for my automobile i do
it over the phone i never even go
into the insurance office and it's the
requirement
that really doesn't need to be um
on our books anymore
well i guess this again shows how old i
will i am because i remember when this
law was created
and it was created because the problem
of people in out of state
coming up and trying to get auto
insurance in new hampshire
so i i assume that the bookkeeping or
regulating and forcing this was more
problems than it's worth
and that's the reason why i would assume
you're correct
representative and um
obviously you have a long background and
knowledge on the institution
and we'll see fit to guide this through
your committee
right well remembering that
all that you sent over to us will be
coming before
me yes that's for sure
uh representative van houten has a
question
uh good morning question to you mr chair
will the insurance company be testifying
because despite the clarity of what the
senator has just presented
i find the wording to maybe be a little
bit difficult
to showcase that clarity uh
i would say do i have i should
i believe they will be testifying today
uh
yes i have james fox yes thank you
any other questions for senator french
yes yes
uh yes uh uh thank you chairman now
senator france does this mean
still mean that somebody out of state
cannot
come into new hampshire or on the phone
purchase
auto insurance they still must be a new
hampshire resident i presume
yes absolutely yeah thank you
okay well thank you very much chris
herbert nothing from you
no he tried to keep his questions it's
just another brilliant piece of
legislative work
by the senator thank you thank you
representative i knew you would think so
thank you all very much okay thank you
very much senator are you guys meeting
today
uh no actually judiciary at one
we need your bill send them over will
you uh uh
yes we will send i think well we
we're done with our bills so oh good
okay have a great day thank you it's
good seeing you here
uh i'm sorry do we have another hand max
did you
represent abramson did you have a
question for senator french
yeah is it not sure this is
correct or not that is it a problem with
somebody who
maybe not somebody who's out of state
somebody who lives here but hasn't
been able to establish residency here
yet when i first moved here uh
there were a lot of different steps if
you hadn't taken a particular order it's
about if they
somebody is moving here buying auto
insurance before they get to new
hampshire
uh this requires that your vehicle is
garaged
here in new hampshire exclusively garage
so i i guess when you get here you can
get it
so all right when i move or i should say
follow-up
further question main claire when i
moved here i i just bought a car
and uh because it was a brand new car i
moved here actually drove here
almost 20 years ago and i didn't have
insurance
and i didn't have really anything on the
car other than the bill of sale
um i wonder if it just makes more sense
in general just to say you know if
you're moving here if your intent is to
move here
you're eventually going to have the car
garage here the
right buy insurance if you see fit make
some changes
good long discussion on that
what's that okay uh thank you very much
senator
thank you chair we'll call on mr fox
from
the department of insurance
uh good afternoon good morning my name
is james fox and i'm the property
counseling director
of the new hampshire insurance
department uh
as a chairman hunt and uh senator french
said um
that this is uh in essence really how
the department sees a modernization bill
um this form has been in place for a
while it was originally in place
due to uh concern over rate invasion
as it's called people come to new
hampshire i'm from new hampshire to buy
insurance
um well i've been at the department now
for
nine years and um we don't have any
issues
on this um so the thought process is uh
we've had
more problems uh with the form
uh because this is the only only state
that requires this is the state of new
hampshire
um and we have the form is
pretty specific so some people can't
meet the requirements of the form who
uh are have an intent to stay here which
is really should be the standard
um as uh representative abramson brought
up
which is the only really standard when
you first come to new hampshire you
haven't you come here and you have an
intense state here
um so the thought process from the
department's point of point of view is
that it would just be
easier to have the basic standards which
is you're either a
a resident which in the rule we view as
you're in new hampshire
and you have an intent to stay in new
hampshire or you're you have your
vehicle so if you're from a different
state you leave your vehicle here
to have a vehicle in new hampshire that
that's also permissible this
and in that sense it really goes back to
basic property insurance that applies to
all types of insurance that
the location of the risk is where the
insurance should be purchased
uh going back to the new hampshire only
issue
the problem from the carrier's
perspective is because it's only a new
hampshire issue
us they have sometimes have a hard time
either um like in certain instances is
recognizing the form so then they don't
recognize the form and then because of
the rule they send out cancellation
notices that shouldn't be sent out
so we do we have seen quite a bit of
that so in essence we have
new hampshire residents who have to go
through the hassle of having
their insurance cancelled or threatened
to be canceled if they don't
work with the insurance company on a
kind of a prolonged basis
um and again for we haven't seen any
rate invasion uh
since i've been here uh and uh from a
regulatory perspective to the extent
that the insurance companies
which we think they are able to aren't
recognizing that certain people
aren't from new hampshire and shouldn't
be getting new hampshire insurance we
can
look at that from a market conduct
perspective
and require corrective actions on the
back end to make sure that insurance
companies are
catching people who might be trying to
get new hampshire insurance although
again
we haven't really seen that but that's
how we would generally handle that's how
we handle things
pretty much in all areas of regulation
so in essence
we're only getting rid of the form we're
keeping all the same standards the
standards aren't changing uh
and uh there should be a benefit
to consumers who maybe are getting
canceled
and to the industry for not having to
comply uh with the rule that doesn't
really
provide much consumer protection and i'd
be happy to take any questions
okay there's an event happening this
question for you
thank you good morning mr fox thank you
for testifying
um
huh i i think connie you have to log
back at
am i okay now right okay cool
i understand the concept of
modernization and simplification that is
intended here
that's absolutely fine i don't
understand the wording um the amendment
the actual wording in the rsa itself has
always baffled me
but now i look at the um uh the change i
don't mean the amendment
look at the change that is requested and
the words at that time
the last three words at that time um
are confusing to me could you explain
what at that time means and if that's
appropriate
yeah if you give me a second to read and
find at that time phrase um
here
[Music]
is she still there i am is my microphone
okay now
yes okay um my the last three words
inserted in roman four uh are
at that time and there's no designation
like that i'm sorry i was i was in the
first section okay
uh
and i apologize for the microphone issue
i've totally confused things and i
apologize for that
yo at that time just refers back too
because that's the part about the
exclusive garaging so the first part is
named insured
was not a resident of the state of new
hampshire at the time the policy
was issued or renewed and then
so that's the the general standard
and then the the exception is unless the
insured vehicle
at issue was exclusively garage in new
hampshire at that time
when they filled out the you know really
the application uh for the initiative
for the initial
policy or the renewal so it's basically
what we're saying is
um hey you're supposed to be a resident
obviously
when you do that but the exception for
that is if you're you know
somebody from rhode island who's got a
house in lake center b and they leave
car there
um maybe it's a four-wheel drive they
don't need to be a resident if that car
stays in centipede uh and uh
every time it's you know you know the
policies issued or renewed basically
it's there
that's the intent of that
okay follow up please
i'll follow up i didn't hear that okay
yes go ahead
i'm sorry i have a puppy in the
background that's um
just had surgery um the um
the word that is confusing to me because
at that time seems to refer
to the time at which the policy is is uh
purchased
that it has to be garaged here at the
time the policy is purchased
i may be just um quibbling about words
here but
it's a reference that is bothersome to
me
well i mean the idea is that it says in
the beginning
you know at the time the policy was
issued or renewed
so that goes back to at the time the
policies
issue or news so we would want the the
property
to be in new hampshire at that time
um and not be like well i have some
intent to do it in the future so i'd
like to get an insurance policy for that
it's like the idea is like at that point
in time
your vehicle is exclusively garaged here
and now the way
we usually do this under the rule is
which if if there's some
you know the other piece we can do if
the statute
is slightly off we can always
you know we're going to have to do the
rule next so we can clean up any of that
in the rule which is more detailed
but the the idea is so if you uh
at the time you you know the policies
issued to you you have your
your car in new hampshire and then later
like you know two months later you've
decided you know what i'm not going to
you had the intent to have it only a
solution gratitude for the policy period
but then you decide to take it back to
rhode island
um then we would let you go which is how
it always works to the end of that
policy period and then we would expect
you to
shift to a rhode island policy so i
think that's kind of why we were saying
at that time
because we need to have a period of time
and it seems as though the correct
period of time is
the intent when the policy was issued or
when the policy renewed because that's
how the rule also operates
thank you i mean i i always find when i
when i write a sentence it's awkward i
just i just
shuffle it so i would you could say that
was the policy was just renewed um
the the vehicles was closely garaged in
new hampshire
uh so it can be added you know at that
time
the vehicle is exclusively garage in new
hampshire numbers move at that time
to the beginning of the phrase rather
than at the end of the phrase maybe that
makes you feel better
and it represents i think we can
definitely just repeat it another way to
do it is just be redund we could just
instead of taking out the time to say it
again same time
okay uh representative fargo
yes thank you mr chair um and thank you
for taking the question could you speak
to um
um line 20 where it says rsa for 12 18
relative to the exclusion of certain
claims in the calculation of
premium rights um
right yeah so that just um
is is to remove that rating issue
because they're they're the old
that uh law says claims paid so
so the old the current version is claims
paid by insurer under policy automobile
insurance as defined rsa 417 issued to
an individual determined
by the truth falsely had tested in the
statement of residency required by 4783b
shall not be included in the calculation
of premium rates filed with the
commissioner if such claims may lawfully
be efficiently be assigned to another
state
uh and that uh is not untrue but we
don't
uh need a uh along basically a law on
that since we don't have the residency
forms that's basically
the old law was saying if if you you
know falsely attest to a residency form
and you're from another state then then
that uh we shouldn't use that to
determine our
rate calculations for the insurance
company like loss
loss experience but again that this has
been
a law that uh although well intended at
the time has not really been used
that i would say i can take a 4 12 18 on
uh signing rates to another state uh
that is i would say never been used
so it's more of an issue if we don't
need it
okay thank you okay representative
abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i guess uh
similar to the question i asked the
sponsor
um if you have a lot of times people buy
a car or truck
in order to move make the move my
preference would be that they
already have insurance
you know at the time that they landed a
fun time coming to new hampshire
they did a road trip here um
is there a way to i guess kind of clean
this up so that
if somebody's buying a car truck and
then they move to new hampshire that
they could have that vehicle insured
before it gets here i mean
well if if you're in new hampshire um
you can get a policy usually what most
people do is they have
their their policy from uh you know a
different state and then
they work with the insurance company who
can be you know multiple states and then
the policy is switched to a new
hampshire policy
uh either when they arrive or at renewal
um
so that's that's the standard um
and that's the rule uh is that when
you're in new hampshire you're entitled
to new hampshire policy
yeah the way i look at that is maybe and
help me out if this is
way is that if you know the day you're
going to move
to new hampshire you can set up ahead of
time
that insurance policy and say that
i don't normally we always say well we
want the policy to be active
today but you wouldn't said is you say i
wanted to be active
and you pick the day that you're going
to move
and so therefore the insurance uh you're
you don't have any lapses between you
two different insurance policies
uh that you've got to make sure that the
other policy expires on you can then
call them and say
i want my old state policy to expire
on the same day and i want my new policy
to
uh take effect on that day so yes you
could actually get the policy
get it get it set up but that you it's
the
uh you can when you get a policy you can
set when
the effective date begins
is that would you agree mr fox yeah
there's two ways people handle it they
either
um they're the people who like to just
let it roll out to renewal and say oh by
the way i'm in new hampshire
uh then it gets switched that time or
people who are more proactive and that
they
let their insurance company know that
they'll be moving to new hampshire on
this date and they'd like to switch to a
new hampshire policy on that date and
then
the insurance company will do that for
you
is that you all said representative
abramson uh follow-up
further question you may inquire um
[Music]
you know as long as that's not your
first car um
my other question is in uh proposed part
four section two part four of the build
where it says unless the vehicle uh
at issue was exclusively garage in new
hampshire at that time
um i live on the border and we have
quite a few people who
their car is garaged either most of the
time or a lot of the time at a place in
seabrook or hampton
and then but they do have the car
overnight
in north shore mass or even in maine uh
should this be a majority of the time or
enough of the time that kind of
justifies keeping the new hampshire
insurance policy
um some cars are some cars are garaged
in
in two different states over the course
of the year
well yeah the intent of this is um to
for
and as for non-residents to be
able to purchase insurance in new
hampshire so that's that's the part of
the
exclusive if you're a new hampshire
resident and you
have multiple um residences uh
you could still get a policy even if
you're in two different states but this
the intent of um the exclusive the
garaging in new hampshire
is that does go back to the the rate
invasion because you don't
we wouldn't want people who are against
jesus from rhode island for example who
come up a lot and then so then they say
oh i come here a lot and then we have to
start doing like counting
uh if either so the purpose of the
non-residence is either
either you have a car that's here or you
don't
and i assume the word garage in the
definition means not necessarily in a
garage but that is parked
in a driveway oh further
uh you disappeared on me oh there you're
way down there okay you have further
questions
you took your hand okay what about all
the people who are parked
at the seabrook walmart
and they're here right now but that
doesn't mean
you know they just got here when you
come up here
they expect to spend most of their time
in new hampshire
wouldn't it be better if those people
want to buy insurance
wouldn't it be better just to open it up
and say they intend to spend
much of the year here shouldn't they be
covered
shouldn't they be able to buy uh auto
insurance coverage for new hampshire
why does it have to be exclusively
they're gonna be driving around a bit
um people who are parked in the parking
lot at the walmart
right now who are in new hampshire a lot
generally insurance and for property
insurance in particular in all
areas not just auto insurance
is um location
uh rated and so that there would be a
concern if it were if you were really
from uh
an area say in massachusetts it has a
high incidence
of accidents and you had your vehicle
there
um you know 50 of the time
and then you were trying to get it
insured in new hampshire uh
the the insurer rating system is based
on new hampshire risks not
on you know massachusetts risk so that
would in essence change
to a certain extent fundamentally change
insurance at least as new hampshire that
we viewed it
from a rating perspective in essence how
much we're going to how much they would
charge
right there's so the assumption is
representative that new hampshire has
insurance rates that are cheaper
than rhode island or massachusetts or
connecticut and i can't necessarily say
maine but so we we don't if those people
are coming up here
uh they we just assume they stick with
the policy they have
from where their residency is not
that they say well i spent enough time
in new hampshire i deserve and i have a
summer home here
i should deserve to have but you know
register my car here
uh and get the lower rates even though i
spend
the winter in the fall and spring
in my home in rhode island
i i guess this is carryover from a
previous bill
we have a lot of people kind of move
around new england and we want to get as
many of those people who are on our
roads
with some kind of insurance rather than
no insurance at all one of them that
have their insurance in those states
everybody else's states requires them to
have insurance so
yes we agree that we wanted to have
insurance but we just don't want them if
they really
live in rhode island or they live in you
know in a lawrence mass where there
seems to be high
claims history down there we certainly
don't want them to
have a new hampshire uh in short car
down there
i mean a lot of them live in an rv you
know go from parking lot to parks
uh that is an interesting question i do
know that there there's the movie right
now out right the nomad movie
so okay representative abel
uh thank you uh very much uh for uh
giving me the opportunity to
ask the question uh of mr fox uh mr fox
um i understand why
this issue would be a prob would be a
concern
of an insurance company uh to make sure
that they're getting the
uh proper uh proper payment
um uh but i'm not sure
why this is of concern to the state of
new hampshire or to the insurance
department
and i wonder from your perspective if
you could explain again
why why this what
the problem is from the state's
perspective
that we're trying to solve here thank
you
um well i guess it depends which way
you're coming at this um the
department's
[Music]
position or the reason we're here is
that the form is unnecessary so
uh to have it uh is um
you know unneeded so there's no reason
to keep it so it
it kind of lowers that um requirement
and then from the consumer's point of
view
some particularly you'll have some
direct writers
and so there's no agent you can go into
their office and sign
sign a form uh so then they either try
to do it online
or they mail it out to you and ask you
to mail it back so you'll have certain
people who don't mail it back
and they'll get a cancellation notice
there are people who do mail it back
and then the insurance company can't
doesn't recognize it it goes into the
wrong box and then they get a
cancellation notice
um so from the department's perspective
uh i think we've determined over the
years that this has caused
more difficulties and has solved no
problems
so it is uh an unnecessary rule
to keep and we'll be able to monitor it
we do market conduct examinations and
claim examinations on
auto insurers quite often so uh you know
we look through all the files and
samples
and if we saw this was all of a sudden a
problem that many
people from other states were trying to
get into new hampshire for uh
insurance rate reasons which was the
reason for the form originally then uh
we would maybe take a different position
but we
have the nine years i've been here we've
examined the auto insurance companies
many times and looked at many claim
files and we've not seen any pattern
or even really instances of people
trying
to get into new hampshire to save um
what would be an extremely modest amount
on
uh on their insurance premiums
may ask a follow-up please certainly for
the question
but thank thank you uh would it not then
be easier
simply to say
that this the the form isn't not
necessary i mean i
uh it just seems like we're doing a lot
of things in order to get rid of a form
here and
and i agree with i agree with another uh
member of the committee earlier who said
that all this
didn't as written it doesn't make it
doesn't seem to say that so
um
[Music]
all this does in essence is we deleted
the form requirement
and then we've inserted the substantive
requirement for residency and uh or
exclusively garage so in the old days
it would just say sign the residency
form
and then you'd look at the rule and the
rule had this language in it so now
since we're getting rid of the
form we take the language from the rule
we put it in
some of it put it in the statute so it
gives guidance as to
the substantive residency requirement
which isn't different than it's always
been so we're not we're not we're
changing nothing's changing and
the insurance companies are fully aware
of uh the
issue of residency
okay representative terry yes uh thank
you
uh mr chairman and uh mr fox
some of my questions have been answered
um in part by the question from
representative abel and the responses by
mr
fox um it's clear to me that
this discussion um is ranging
uh is broadening beyond the actual
um request to eliminate the form
so uh in that spirit i would just like
to
add or ask one additional question and
that is with respect to the monitoring
that the department does
uh with respect to compliance um
how many staff do you actually have that
are engaged in this practice
and how aggressive is it i believe you
had indicated that it's really not much
of a problem at all
so if you could address that or speak to
that i appreciate it
sure uh so we have uh what's called a
market conduct
unit uh and that has uh
four members and i assist and
they um in essence we have
different issues that come up and we do
um examinations
so which is uh the insurance companies
pay for them we go to their building
and uh well you know currently we do it
here uh
and then we we do a sample of files and
we review those files
and then we ensure compliance with
new hampshire law one of the forms or
different types of exams we do we can do
underwriting exams for example what do
we do is claims exams
so in this case um we do claimed exams
i would say yearly uh and
you know if we saw uh like i know one
auto insurer is coming up and if we saw
this
you know that we've changed the law we
get rid of the residency form and
now uh people who have the
um seem to seem to not be from new
hampshire then we would catch that and
then we
we would either correct we might
discuss it with that insurance company
in what's called a trek
corrective action order uh and now that
insurance company then could say well
we think other insurance companies are
having the same problem then we might do
a bulletin or we might come back to
legislature and say okay here's
here's the new status and here's what we
think would be the best
fix for this so it's kind of always an
ongoing process
now lay it on top of that we also have a
consumer division
um and so if um
there was an issue and that's how for
example we determined that
some of the uh some of the direct
writers were having a little bit of
trouble
uh recognizing the forms because we had
consumers call us and say
um i got cancelled you know i should not
have been canceled i've been
in new hampshire for you know my whole
life so that's how we caught that issue
so there are probably
multiple ways that we we catch
uh issues that are hurting consumers but
in terms of
our team we have four dedicated people
plus myself and then we also have
additional people we can put in place if
we need to
okay follow mr pierre if i'm like sure
thank you mr fox so uh thank you
so um in terms of monitoring it sounds
like this is an annual exercise
by sample by insurance company is that
correct
well i guess yeah that this i should say
that there's another
layer complete layer that's that's
different than the new hampshire
insurance department
we uh the insurance companies also have
to do
uh reporting uh on a national
basis which would include new hampshire
and we have in addition to the four
people i just mentioned we also have an
analyst
and the analyst agrees
he reviews uh all of the national data
and then if that national data indicates
uh a problem then he'll go to our market
conduct chief
and then we'll do we'll start with an
investigation so for example
if you had an insurance company uh with
a very high cancellation rate
we would then um contact that
in that particular insurance company the
analysis team would
and then try to figure out why is your
cancellation rate so high
and that would be another way um to show
that
um the residency form has been a problem
so there's def there are many ways about
this but there is national monitoring on
of insurance companies which includes
new hampshire and we get all of that
data
and we have an analyst here who goes
through all that data every year to try
to
see if there are problems
thank you okay uh we thank you very much
mr fox chair we'll now call on
attorney james hit him
good morning jim
you there jim i'm here okay
good morning thank you mr chairman
members of the committee uh i am jim
haydem
here testifying in support of this bill
on behalf of state farm insurance
company which is
the nations and perhaps new hampshire's
largest writer of
automobile insurance um
i too go back to when this law was put
on the books
in 20 2004
and this this law
was prompted by a former commissioner
who had a house on lake winnipesaukee
and after he bought it he realized that
a lot of his neighbors
were showing up on weekends in cars that
were registered in new hampshire
and after thinking about the situation
and talking about it he
he believed that there was a issue
relating to
non-residents
registering their cars in new hampshire
and insuring them in new hampshire
and thus put this law on the books or
ask the legislature to put this ball in
the book
since that time i've been wrestling with
this long behalf
of state farm because state farm
is has unique business practice that
goes back to the inception
of the company or the beginning of the
companies where it actually
issues a new policy for each vehicle
that you insure so if you're somebody
who buys a car
for the kids or buys a trailer
uh or buys a motorcycle every time you
buy another vehicle
an insurance other vehicle with state
farm that triggered a
residency statement that needed to be
signed
and it required the consumer to come
down to the local state farm agent to
sign it
state farm has not been able to figure
out how to get this
form uh onto some kind of electronic
filing or electronic signing mostly
because a lot of consumers don't really
like that and don't know how to use it
but the point is this is a this is a
a forum that is no longer necessary and
it remains
the biggest issue with the state farm
agents new hampshire
and rather than being a direct writer
the state farm
is is actually
has agents in new hampshire that are
roughly 50 or 60 of the mom and pop
businesses that provide state farm
insurance throughout new hampshire
so i even renewed a policy or actually
got a new car policy and it was
the customer service rep with my local
state farm agent actually complained
about the form when she asked me to sign
it
not knowing exactly who she was talking
to uh
but she expressed interest and
excitement about
the fact that the legislature may do
away with the form
um and so i here testify and support all
these agents who are looking closely at
this
because they would love to see his form
disappear
um the the intricacy of the bill
and james explained it is that you know
when the way the law is written it
basically says
to an insurance company or to a consumer
if you lie
on this form uh you can be denied
coverage
and that's a pretty powerful statement
this is telling a consumer you're not
going to get insurance onto your
under your policy so because
the um because this this dramatic
event was tied to the policy form um
you know the department needed to create
wording when eliminating the form that
sort of loosened it up
basically telling consumers you can't
lie about your residency
but they had to sort of decouple it from
this form
um it's true that this
uh to my knowledge there's no other
state in the new hampshire that has this
residency requirement on its books and
the full
statement that you do not get coverage
if you lie about your residency that's
that's
a pretty powerful uh statement from the
legislature and i haven't researched it
but i've never heard it told that
other states have gone this far um
but i can tell you that you know in the
17 years that i've been
wrestling with this this requirement
there's only been one claim in all that
time
that had a residency statement issue
that we had to deal with so over the
course of 17 years it only came up once
um and you know i think that if you take
a step back
and you think through what uh how people
are moving around
and how cars are being insured i think
you know this is a this is a requirement
this is a concept
that is long outdated and getting rid of
the forum
will certainly update new hampshire laws
to be more consumer friendly and more
consumer compatible
um and to the extent you know there's
other aspects of residency that need to
be considered
that that could be for a later day but i
i i
would encourage you to support this bill
mostly for the benefit of the agents
who have to deal with it every day and
would very much look forward to
removing the form from as a requirement
under new hampshire law
so with that uh i will lend and
certainly answer questions if anyone has
representative mclaren has a question
for you um
yes it never really occurred to me that
you somebody would try to get insurance
in new hampshire
uh to save money but what did occur to
me and does occur to me
is if i have a second residence in new
hampshire which for
a long time i did i would want to
register my car
in new hampshire as opposed to
massachusetts
uh because of the sales tax that's
that's a much much bigger bite than the
insurance
um how do we address that is this this
isn't going to
help us out in that if a sense if
somebody
in fact you know simply registers their
car in new hampshire to
avoid the sales tax how how do we get
around that
i'm going to respectfully say that you
know there's many
uh issues that when you mention the word
residency it plays out in other areas
and there's other aspects of this
um and you know this this bill is very
narrowly
tailored to the residency forum and
you know i don't think it goes beyond
that in its present form
even though i agree through that could
be another issue
great thank you very much i have one
more person who wants to
testify and that's uh bruce berkey
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee uh thank you and
and uh for your record my name is bruce
berkey
and i'm appearing uh before you today on
behalf of the
professional insurance agents of new
hampshire
and they are opposed to senate bill 36
for a variety of reasons and and frankly
for some of the reasons that you've
heard
here this morning
currently an individual seeking coverage
for their automobile insurance must
sign this statement of residency prior
to obtaining the coverage there are a
couple of exceptions
one having been mentioned if the vehicle
is garaged here in new hampshire
and the other is for another is for
active military members
but it does make clear that anyone whose
primary residence
is outside of new hampshire cannot
obtain
automobile insurance as a state resident
except under those specific
circumstances
it's only required on the application
for the automobile insurance
this form it is not required for
renewals
as i understand it a renewal can
take place uninterrupted without the
need for the additional statement if no
changes to residency occur
it makes the law clear to consumers it
is a legal statement
and it guarantees that every person
seeking to buy
automobile insurance in new hampshire
has been made aware of this law
and the consequences for violating it
we have some of the lowest rates
in the country your chairman has
mentioned
that um especially as it compares to
southern new england
doing away with this law this
requirement could potentially disrupt
new hampshire's stable and affordable
in short automobile insurance market the
rates in the state
reflect the risks of resident drivers
altering the rating pool with
non-resident drivers could change the
rates for new hampshire consumers
carriers would still be able to deny
coverage for losses by anyone who
wrongfully claims
a new hampshire residency further
disrupting the marketplace
the potential increases to uninsured
motorist claims that would further risk
rate increases for new hampshire drivers
increasing the cost
of automobile insurance throughout new
hampshire
now i never like to go against the
department
but i i would just like to point out
that in mr fox's statements
and frankly uh mr hayden's statements
and and jim's a personal friend of mine
but
they've both said you know the law has
been on the books since 2004
and we haven't seen a problem that's a
good thing
they've basically told my story that
having this law in place it has enabled
you know new hampshire residents to
access insurance here and for
massachusetts residents
not to access insurance here if there's
a problem with the form
then let's change the form let's update
the form
both from an electronic perspective and
from
a clarity perspective
i we we're not having the rate invasion
that
mr fox mentioned and
because you know we're we we have this
form in place
and so it's a protection for new
hampshire consumers
we would urge you to to maintain the
form
maybe maintain some of the language in
in the the new language that's being
presented
for statutory purposes and to
direct the department to update the form
i'll close my testimony there and i'll
be happy to
try and address any questions any
members of the committee has
we do have a question representative
abramson has a question
yeah um i've noticed that uh according
to
how much.net that uh the automotive
average automotive insurance premium is
about a hundred dollars a year lower in
vermont
if someone were shopping around say they
were the new england market why wouldn't
they
just pick a vermont policy and save even
more money why would they
why would this even be a problem people
buying their insurance in new hampshire
if they know they can save even more
money
i'm not sure if i entirely understand
the question representative ravenson but
if you're if you're suggesting that they
would
try to buy insurance in vermont rather
than new hampshire
i guess i would defer to the department
of insurance in vermont
and their laws with respect to how that
would be addressed
well i mean i think the answer is that
they don't have a summer home in vermont
they have a summer home in
new hampshire and that's why they want
to register in new hampshire
well i'm just looking at the the list
they're actually quite a few states
around the country that have lower
there's no doubt and that the more rural
the state is the lower the
uh rates rates are that is true
so but i would say is that at the end of
the day you've got to have a place where
you
are you're somehow garaging it or
someplace you're putting the car or some
place the rationale
that you have an address so if you don't
have any connection
uh i mean i remember when we were first
debating the issue was that there were
some people
were registering into a p.o box and that
that
was an issue and that's why they wanted
you you got to give us a real address
you can't use a p.o box
but uh okay uh representative van halen
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
berkey as i listened to you speak and
looked back
at the uh the bill as it stands now
um i'm struck by the fact that we are
talking about the form
and elimination of the form and yet the
wording here really doesn't
address the form do you see what i'm
speaking about and would you respond to
that
concern please sure as
as i understand it with the way that the
bill is written when you where you see
in section two roman four
the language being stricken failure to
sign the new hampshire residency form
so there's that aspect to the bill
and then in the very last uh paragraph
of the bill
section three roman two it repeals
uh 417 a3b
which is the um uh
the authorization for the form as i
understand it it's the statement of
residency
and it has the form uh requirement built
into that section of the statute
thank you you're all set okay um
bring up this issue to the senate we did
not
um we had a uh a meeting uh
just the last week of the week before
the insurance agents did
and that's when they took their official
position in opposition to senate bill
36.
and you're not the independent agent
you're the professional agent
my memory for professional uh insurance
agents of new hampshire yes
okay so you all sat then connie right
you're
i am thank you you still had your hand
up okay okay
uh we thank you very much uh just when i
thought we had an easy bill
it turns out it's not so easy so um
having no more people signed up i guess
i should look at the attendees make sure
there's no hand pop up on me
and i will close the public hearing on
senate bill 36
there were representative terry has his
hand up
oh i didn't even see that sorry
representative did you have a question
for
thank you mr chairman i was going to ask
um what uh the
the man who testified what would be the
impact um
uh would he assess uh what would be the
impact
on um on this uh on this change if it
were to be approved
what adverse impact representative terry
um this is rick berkey i assume the
question was addressed to me
i'm certainly not an actuary so i i
cannot give you
specific numbers um but it
you know if if there was a a uh
a rising in claims an increase in claims
that could have an adverse impact on the
overall market within new hampshire
and therefore have a an impact on new
hampshire consumers and the rates they
pay
follow mr chairman another question
thank you so this is this is
hypothetical
uh because there's no actuary data
mr fox testified on behalf of the
insurance
department that new hampshire is the
only state that has this
requirement so are you familiar with any
adverse
impacts in other any of the other 49
states by not having this provision
i am not but i'd be happy to try and
research that for you
thank you good luck with that
thanks well then i'll put those
professional agents to work on this one
that's right all right but now i will
close the public hearing see no more
hands up
uh and say that there were 15 support
uh at the time this was printed there
was none of opposition
and two were neutral and with that we'll
close the public hearing
on senate bill 36 and we'll open up the
public hearing
on uh senate bill 49.
and i understand that uh
senator d'alessandro would not be able
to make it so
uh i will have
to uh yeah glenn okay i got you i
finally glenn all right don't move on me
all right i promote you to payless so uh
glenn perlow
uh will uh present uh
senate bill 49 good afternoon
or morning excuse me it got me all
confused
uh you're speaking to me mr chairman yes
i am glenn it's you're on
good morning am i a proxy for
introducing this bill
yes thank you i thought i thought lou
told you that you were gonna do that
oh yeah no i just didn't know if uh
senator bradley might have been
coming so now happy too happy to do that
no senator bradley's here
but go ahead absolutely happy to do so
uh for the record
uh my name is glenn perlow i'm general
counsel and chief compliance officer at
jordan park trust company and i'm also
president of the new hampshire trust
council i
am a registered lobbyist um and i'm here
to
speak in favor of senate bill 49
um mr chairman if possible could i ask
that my colleague patrick collins
also be given an opportunity to share
the mic
um well i'll tell you what since you
want to share the mic let's
have senator bradley speak first because
he is here
he is here thank you so we'll let him
speak and then you can and who's the
person you want to
patrick collins oh i see him yep okay
go ahead and uh good morning uh senator
bradley
you just have to unmute yourself jim
there we go sorry about that good
morning
mr chairman members of the commerce
committee um senator d'allesandro could
not be here this morning so he asked me
to sub for him i just want to thank
chairman hunt for joining with myself
and senator d
over the years to update our trust laws
in new hampshire we have
tried to make this state
a very friendly state to be able to
locate
a trust or in competition with states
like delaware in particular
but also south dakota and florida
for the kind of jobs that come with
um trust being incorporated in a state
so i'm just going to stop there because
i think mr perlow probably can go
through the particulars of the bill
for you better than i can but i i think
the
big picture is that we have had a number
of trust companies
located in new hampshire these are good
jobs and we should continue
to be at the cutting edge of what makes
a state attractive for trust so
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your leadership on this issue
too no problem thank you
okay uh so now i will call on patrick
collins
since we don't have a tag team we can't
have two and two at the desk at the same
time
so good morning mr collins
good morning i think glenn is gonna if
it's okay
kick it off and then i'm gonna be more
of a uh uh
available for questions to help with any
technical pieces but glenn can give a
good overview of the job
okay still beyond and might
so yes i see you're both good to mike's
run yes okay
thanks very much um but uh before i
begin let me echo
uh one thing senator bradley said and i
i think i mentioned this briefly when i
had the opportunity to introduce myself
several months ago to the committee
but i would want to reiterate that um uh
we've presented
this committee with empirical data
regarding job growth and all that uh
in the past couple of years um but i can
definitely speak anecdotally
uh to our trust company jordan park
trust company
previously was prospective trust company
was established in 2007
and we recently were acquired by a much
larger registered investment advisor
out of san francisco with offices in new
york
and now new hampshire and not only is
our census
um scheduled to grow as we
simply take on new business uh but also
it's very clear that this company is uh
hiring in new hampshire
and citing people for uh our sister
investment advisor company uh and that's
precisely what we've been after
uh with that said the other thing i i
said the last time we spoke was
we're sensitive to two things uh what
you're challenged with in terms of the
covet pandemic and
getting through legislation uh but also
we're sensitive to criticism in the past
that we've been very energetic
in providing you with reams of of uh
paper uh so i'm happy to point out that
this is a two-page
bill it's very targeted uh and it
is uh designed to help uh settlers of
trusts
uh uh beneficiaries of trust and also
enable
trustees to do a better job for them uh
so quickly
the first section of the bill and i did
provide the written testimony
which goes into a little bit more detail
but the first section
deals with representation which is um
when you have beneficiaries
who uh may be underage maybe uh special
needs or in some other way
need someone to represent their
interests with regard to a trust
this simply expands a list of seven
different folks with different
characteristics to also include
the person who settled the trust in
terms of giving them the opportunity to
name
a trusted friend an organization um you
know someone to
uh to uh assert representation
and we just think this is a miss that uh
should have been there
all along uh secondly um
and this one is really an administrative
efficiency issue
very often uh older trusts that have
provisions that are more difficult
to uh to follow or have some other
change that ought to be made
are decanted or poured into a second
trust
and it's not been clear under new
hampshire law whether or not you need to
create a new
trust and when you create a new trust
obviously that's extra
expense um in terms of drafting that
but also then you're required to go out
and get a new uh
federal tax number for the trust so what
this will allow is
uh several variations of that theme that
adds some efficiency by allowing you to
use an existing trust
and not necessarily changing the tax
number it's consistent with federal law
and it gives some flexibility to save
some money and time
uh and finally the last section uh very
often
um particularly in a trust where the
grantor is no longer involved with said
law or they've passed away
um you've got beneficiaries and the the
the trust never said exactly how things
should be invested
but you may have a group of
beneficiaries who are like-minded
and it may be that there's a specific
company they want to invest in or they
may want to invest in
uh not invest in a category of companies
um and what this is a lot allows is a
settlement agreement amongst the
beneficiaries
um only in certain circumstances but it
allows them to give a directive to the
trustee and it says
if you invest as directed by this group
of beneficiaries
and that is not optimal in terms of
return
uh you're not on the hook as a fiduciary
because you were directed under the law
so uh in a nutshell that's the bill if
anyone would like to deep dive on any of
that patrick will be
better equipped to do that and i thank
you for your time
okay uh seeing no direct questions we'll
go right
right to uh mr collins
i think i think glenn generally thank
you for for having me i think glenn
generally wants me here just in case
there are any
technical questions uh i don't have
anything
further to add to his uh his general
overview of the bill
okay okay so uh any members of the
committee have any questions
uh seen none we thank you oh
you have reverence and mclare uh yes
thank you very much uh mr chairman
uh two questions if i might um
would a family llc
fit into the definition of a trust under
this
law and actually under existing new
hampshire laws
uh i i'm gonna uh i'm gonna suggest that
you're asking about
a family trust company in an llc form
correct uh
directly none of this legislation uh
addresses that as a company that
that uh it's in and of itself is not a
trust and this legislation is all
addressing uh new hampshire trust code
permissions
second question um how long
can a family trust or go on
in new hampshire is it perpetual or
is there a final generational
stop there is no final generational stop
under the um under the either uh
chartered
or uh self-regulated family trust
companies
um are perpetual like like any other
company just to add to that question
would that include an llc then or not
yeah if by yes a family trust company in
the form of an llc
um has no particular uh time
limit and trust which a family trust
company exists to
administer for the family those trusts
uh can exist in perpetuity under new
hampshire law that's a
major feature of new hampshire thank you
yeah i was the sponsor of the repeal of
rural
of perpetuity and that was a long time
ago so we appreciate it that was my one
of my first trust spills that i put in
and so representative herbert you have a
question
thank you can you hear me yes we can
okay just this is i don't want to
go sideways here but uh what
the fiduciary uh responsibility
it sounded to me as though uh the uh the
benefit
beneficiaries could instruct the
fiduciary to
make an investment that may not be
all that wise and so and
and and i if i heard correctly the
fiduciary uh
has the ability to uh not be
involved or or not be
a fiduciary you know what i'm saying
because
i a fiduciary to me has a certain
meaning in terms of their
responsibility uh towards the
family or the beneficiaries uh in
in this this law apparently
brings up the issue of being a fiduciary
in conflict uh with the beneficiary's
desires
to make an investment of some sort i
mean
is that are you still are you still a
fiduciary if that happens
patrick i see you unmuted i i'd be happy
to start the answer to this question i
think patrick may be able to help out as
well
so so uh a fiduciary uh
yes is the short answer to are you still
a fiduciary
um and you know a trustee
in new hampshire in many places uh can
take many forms
and in some cases you are a directed
trustee with a more limited set of
fiduciary duties
and in this case essentially um
this is directing that fiduciary and
it's really
an exception to the prudent investor
rule
so if you look at how this uh how the
actual language of legislation
uh fits in under the prudent investor
rule there are a
series of exceptions um uh
cases or not exceptions i shouldn't say
but factors
that the fiduciary uh canon and
should take into account um when
deciding on investing
for example and in in in this case
what it's saying is if there is uh and
you know you can concentrate
for example the situation maybe that the
trust owns a business
and it is completely rational that the
purpose of the trust is to own that
business
that is a concentration of the assets of
the trust
in one investment which would ordinarily
be
uh you know against the general
fiduciary duty commissioners generally
spread out investments they they're
avoiding loss
but it's circumstantially allowed um
because in many circumstances that's the
appropriate thing to do
so what this is saying is uh first of
all
there's no certainty that this type of
investing there's no
evidence that it's uh better or worse
from a return standpoint
but it's saying that this is a factor
that you can take into account so if
you're directed to do this you can do
this
and it's not a violation of your
fiduciary it certainly doesn't relieve
you of being a fiduciary
yeah i would only add that's well said i
would only add that if
the in a trust context the fiduciary
which is the trustee owes a fiduciary to
two duty to two people
two groups of people one is the settler
of the trust and that is to carry out
the terms
of the trust if there's specific
investment instructions they have to
follow those instructions the second
group is to the beneficiaries and what
this law is doing is saying if the
beneficiaries unite
and say hey we want to we want to invest
in esg
related investments we don't want uh to
have investments for
fossil fuels or so on and so forth if
they combine in an agreement with them
and the trustees the uh
uh the fiduciary duty in that context is
is uh effectively
modifying the traditional um
uh duties under the prune investor rule
to allow for this investment
only if they're all in it together all
the beneficiaries agree
that this is a uh you know an investment
that they want and so it's it's
changing the fiduciary duty in that
context but only
from the parties who would be affected
by that decision
and also only if it in no way is
adverse to any material in terms of the
trust so if the
sedler contrary to the wishes of the
beneficiary had set out that
uh you know there shall be a
concentration or you shall never let go
of that exxon stock
that made this fortune um then you
couldn't do this
uh because that would be a material term
of the trust and this would be contrary
so it's really only where the situation
is everybody
uh who should have a say has uh got on
the same page and said this is how we
would like to do it and we're willing to
take the risk so
what happens if the beneficiaries want
to spend down
and say okay we just want to dissolve
this thing can they
say we want to cash out
that's a that's a sort of whole other
question unrelated to this legislation
but patrick i would defer to you
yeah typically the this this bill here
is not allowing the beneficiaries to
unite in that way and say we'd rather
have this money in our hands than in the
trust you can't
do that by virtue of this bill uh
certainly they could
try to do that under other provisions of
the trust code but
the trust code is pretty limiting in
allowing a beneficiary to
basically unwind the trust and terminate
it uh
early earlier than was contemplated by
just the nature of the investment not
necessarily
exactly spend it yeah right mr chairman
it happens that the the statutory
provision in which this
makes sense to insert it um is in regard
it is using a mechanism uh of a
non-judicial settlement agreement and
there are a variety of circumstances
where things can be changed
but always within the four corners of
the trust
fair enough uh representative fargo oh
yes thank you mr chair are we gonna hear
any testimony from the banking
commissioner or the banking department
on this
uh evidently they have not signed up for
this bill
but if i may uh representative fargo um
we
follow a pretty strict process as they
do and we
sort of all do together of stakeholder
uh
information and involvement and so this
was provided
to the banking department and discussed
now i want to say three or four months
ago
um and also provided to well over 50
trust and estates uh attorneys who
gathered together to look at legislation
um also i've worked with the charitable
trust director
on some of the specific language which
you can spot in the
statute or in the legislation um
and the bankers association was also
part of our stakeholder discussion
thank you hey representative abel
yes thank you both for for testifying
and explaining things uh of all the
areas that perhaps this committee covers
for many of us including me
trusts are one of the harder ones to
completely understand my question
is what was the impetus
for for uh for this bill
for introducing this bill um
and what what are the problems what are
things that
uh are prevented from being done now
that this bill would
would solve i guess what problems are we
solving here thank you
i'll speak to the impetus and i'll let
patrick speak as a practitioner to the
to the problems but
um we we uh as an organization the the
trust council
um we uh collect and we think on
both our existing trust code and what's
going on here and then of course
we watch other states sometimes that's
kind of an arms race thing
but most often it's not most often it's
just it's an active profession
uh with a lot of dialogue and um you
know constantly looking for ways to
lubricate the system so it's easier for
settlers and
clients um and also just to
to fix up anything that somebody may see
an issue with
these three provisions came from sort of
three different quarters
and i can tell you with regard to the
esg the third
major uh provision um this is something
that several members of
the trust council are finding just more
and more their clients are asking
hey can we you know do something about
how things are invested
um and so this was this was floated and
vetted
and um and seemed to be an opportunity
for clarity
uh so that trustees can meet their
clients needs
uh patrick i'll let you go maybe through
each quickly
as to what it does for a client
particularly obviously for the client
the settler
and or beneficiaries yeah sure it's
great great question
uh representative i i think the first
one dealing with uh with representation
is is trying to uh avoid the spoiled
child
uh and we have a provision in the trust
code
currently that allows for what are
called quiet trusts
uh that allow a trustee to not disclose
the terms or the assets in a trust
uh to uh to really beneficiaries
until you know usually they reach a
certain age or some life event
what is what is missing is that while
that beneficiary
doesn't know what's going on
intentionally to try to avoid you know
the spoiled child syndrome
uh we don't have a provision that allows
someone to be representing them
uh while they're in the dark if if you
will so this allows
uh someone to represent the
beneficiary's interest
while they're not aware of the trust's
existence
so we think this is a good beneficiary
rights
provision the second one for decanting
which is a procedure whereby
you take the assets of one trust and
decant them into a second trust usually
to modernize or update the trust
provisions
there's a uh there's a
procedural um nuance that's not
clear in the statute as to whether or
not you need to actually
create a second trust meaning
a trust with a different name which
would require that you re-title all the
assets
which can be a cumbersome time consuming
expensive process
so this is saying look if you do a
decanting you can keep the same name of
the trust you don't have to retitle
everything and go through all that
rigmarole and you can also keep the same
tax id number so you don't have to
um you know file a whole separate tax
return
so on and so forth uh so just it just
makes that process more efficient
and then the third one i think glenn
spoke to which is
just trying to find a way to uh
one on the one hand from a marketing
standpoint make new hampshire
uh you know again an attractive state i
don't know of any other state that has
specifically
put into their trust code a provision
or a statute that allows for
esg investing through a non-judicial
settlement agreement
so it will it will highlight new
hampshire as a unique state in that
context
and secondly to serve the
uh you know the clients of of of
new hampshire trust companies uh that
that are specifically looking for this
uh as a way to uh provide more
flexibility
and and selfishly on behalf of the trust
company
uh to to uh limit the liability that a
trustee may otherwise
be confronted with uh in making an esg
investment that might
run counter to the prune investor rule
without such an agreement in place
patrick you want to explain what esg
means because i'm sure
not everybody knows yeah so it's it's um
a type of investment that is
um uh focused on environmental social
and governance objectives so it's
it's really to give a practical example
it's
those people that want to have an
investment that is not
furthering uh some environmental
uh uh aspect of uh
you know in the world so so for example
they may say we don't want to be
invested in fossil fuels
so we want to make a directive that the
trust not
further fossil fuel investments and
instead invest
in environmentally friendly companies
if i might add though it's broader than
that and i think it's
it's easy because it's got this label
environmental social governance
more and more the dialogue is about
governance
and uh liability risk that
certain certain large corporations bring
um and so for sophisticated investors
there's more of a focus
these days to get really into the nuts
and bolts of a company
is that company run in a manner that i
like
so it it is not left or right
or or progressive or it's it's uh
it could be anything it's the
concentration the directive
to do an investment that's very specific
as opposed to
you know a broad-based kind of mutual
fund type of
of investing that's often the case when
you're just preserving the trust asset
okay perfect thank you any other
questions from the committee members
okay seeing none no hands going up
okay so we'll close the public hearing
on the senate bill 49 we had 10 in
support no
opposition there was one person who was
neutral
and with that we will close that public
hearing
and then get to the two exciting ones
okay
so we'll open up uh senate bill 68
and i did see senator hennessey
uh over there uh senator hennessey you
want to raise your hand so i can
pop to the top for me there you go thank
you
okay so you were under senator that's
why i didn't see you
okay good morning senator
good morning chairman hunt and honorable
members of the house commerce committee
good to see you all again
i'm here to introduce senate bill 68
requiring an
employer to provide reasonable
accommodations for pregnant employees
this is one of the bills that faced a
pandemic death last year
in the house sorry my dog all of a
sudden wants to come up
and i am reintroducing it it had
overwhelming bipartisan support
in the senate and is one of the
governor's priorities you should
have in your email in box a letter of
support from governor sununu for this
bill
and what it does is uh it requires
employers in the state to provide
reasonable accommodations to help women
stay in the workforce longer it it helps
women maintain a healthy pregnancy
it helps improve job retention for women
in the state
it helps bolster new hampshire's economy
it helps
ultimately attract younger generations
to
come to new hampshire stay in new
hampshire and all sorts of wonderful
things
it does have a um a
and out for employers if there's um
on line 9 and 10 in the
in the bill it says unless each employer
can demonstrate that the accommodation
would impose an
undue hardship on the operation of an
employer's business
but this bill would put into law things
um the accommodations and these
accommodations can be very simple things
like
allowing more uh bathroom breaks during
a work
period it can allow and
more shorter breaks it can allow extra
water breaks it can allow having a
bottle of water at their workstation
and a lot of these things can be worked
out between the employer and the
employee
and i think it's just good overall
legislation for new hampshire and i'd
also like to thank
the executive director malachi from the
commission on human rights and the
attorney general's office
for all their hard work on the senate
side in helping to
listen to all of the outside concerns
some of which were outside of new
hampshire
and to make sure that the wording of
this bill is what's best for new
hampshire
thank you okay
any questions yes we do we have some
several questions represented van halen
you have to mute unmute
you hear me now yes we can i apologize
i'm having technical difficulties in so
many ways today and i apologize for that
thank you senator for bringing this to
us um i have a question about the
wording
um i the intent and and some of the
examples you gave as simple as just
um rehydration during work
uh are very important and yet the bill
itself as stated here
talks about a period of temporary
physical disability
would you respond to the need for that
wording please
uh the period of temporary disability
that refers to
or permit a female employee to take
leave of absence
so that refers to a leave of absence and
not to reasonable accommodations on the
on in the actual work environment
thank you okay uh
representative burrows
yes thank you for taking my question um
i i
i appreciate and um support the um
intent of the bill um i'm just wondering
it just the wording is just so
i don't know what the word to use
nebulous it's it
as i'm i'm just wondering how this is
going to be enforced i mean how long
um could a temporary uh is a temporary
leave of absence
and what specific reasonable uh
accommodations would an employer need to
make it's just so
um wide open that i just wonder if it
has any teeth to it so i was wondering
if you could respond to that
i think i well there may be other people
on the line that could
respond to the how long but there's
temporary disability laws in the state
and i don't know all of those
um but as far as uh what a reasonable
accommodation
is that the the wording has been vetted
by different business groups by
the ag's office by the humans right
commission and this is
this is the wording that everyone agreed
on and
in in the maybe the vagueness of it is
that everyone's
um reasonable accommodation is going to
be different
if i am a person at a um
at a that's a cashier and doing checkout
all day long
my reasonable accommodation may be a
high-top stool that i can sit on
or a water bottle at my checkout station
if i am a person who is doing heavy
lifting
and um in a warehouse facility my
reasonable accommodation may be a
temporary
change of workspace to do data entry
instead of heavy lifting
so it's it's different for everyone and
that's why it can't be
specifics can't be addressed in the bill
follow up please
for the question main query so just a
hypothetical
if um if a woman uh feels a reasonable
accommodation
um need uh that needs frequent uh
bathroom breaks i mean like two an hour
let's just say that and the
employer doesn't feel that's reasonable
how does that get resolved
um the resolution would go through the
commission on for human rights i believe
and that can be confirmed by um director
malachi when she speaks later
thank you representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for introducing this bill
um i'm looking at the undue hardship and
it looks like the burden is put on the
employer um
how much is the undue partnership is is
it an amount of money
10 000 per employee or is it i mean
how's it calculated
how how can it be made predictable i
don't know the answer to that question
i think it would be different in in
everyone's case and it would be
it would follow through the commission
on humans rights
process so they might be able to answer
that question but i think it would be
different for every employer
okay follow-up further question you may
inquire
[Music]
not to completely change gears but if
the burden does become two pion
employers
with this bill as written would make it
tougher for women of child-bearing age
to find work especially in management or
specialist position medical specialist
some other
conditions i don't believe so
okay uh uh representative greeson
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator uh for your testimony this
morning uh
my question is how how much of a problem
is it for uh pregnant employees
to be able to discuss with their
employer
some sort of extra break or something
like that i to me
it seems foreign to mistreat my
employees
i've had pregnant employees in the past
and it just was foreign to me to
deny them restroom breaks or water at
their station
so how much of a widespread problem is
this that we need to codify this into
law
i i don't believe the the problem is
widespread in new hampshire
and i i agree i think we have some great
employers out there
this is to put into law that new
hampshire
appreciates uh pregnant women
and will help to accommodate their their
needs in the workplace
and if for um if there is an instance
where
a woman cannot come to agreement with
her employer that this is what the
reason is for and someone else on the
line might be able to go
further into your question thank you
okay uh thank you very much senator
thank you uh chairman hunt thank you
you'll stick around for the next bill i
think
okay back to you
okay uh now so we have um
miss malachi um
all right there you are okay
all right she is the last one here so
she'll wrap it up
and i assume you'll attempt to answer
these some of these questions that
have been left are out there
so good morning
yes good morning this is ani malachi
the screen went blank and then i'm back
again so am i
testifying now you're on you're alive
okay very good i'll turn my camera on
here uh good morning everyone uh
thank you very very much chairman hunt
and for the rest of the committee
members thank you and good morning
um before i go into responses
relative to sb 68 i just wanted to go
over a few things some of you i've seen
in other
committees before but i wanted to give a
little background
um as to the commission and what we do
and some of that may
answer some of the questions that you've
asked um
and or may provide answers for questions
you haven't asked as of yet
so as i said before my name is ani
malachi and i'm the executive director
for the commission
for human rights the commission is a
state agency
and we have been established by rsa
354-a for the purposes
of eliminating discrimination in the
state of new hampshire
in employment housing places of public
accommodation
and as recently as 2019 k-12 education
was added to our statute the commission
is comprised of seven
volunteer commissioners who provide
oversight and make
decision on charges of discrimination
and each commissioner is appointed by
the governor
with the consent of the executive
council for a term of five years
the commission has the power to receive
investigate and pass upon complaints
of illegal discrimination and to engage
in research
education and community outreach
designed to prevent discrimination
in the state in addition to the powers
vested
in the commission by rsa 354-a to
enforce new hampshire's laws against
discrimination
the commission also partners with the
eeoc which is the u.s
equal employment opportunities
commission to enforce federal laws
prohibiting discrimination in employment
and we have a very small staff so
we cover the entire state of new
hampshire with our
with our small staff so we have five
investigators myself
is the executive director we have an
assistant director and
uh recently hired a paralegal um and we
also
have uh limited admin staff
um so one of the things i wanted to go
over relative to
sb 68 is in cooperation
with um last session with
senator jeb bradley um we we constructed
this bill now sb 68
what it will do is codify what the
commission
has done since 1965 when we were
established
pregnancy is something that we
take charges on uh it's not rampant uh
but we do take charges of discrimination
in this area
currently so what sp 68 does is it puts
it
it answers the question and speaks
specifically to
what we do relative to pregnancy
puts it all in one place makes it easy
for people to find
and i'm not sure were there any other
were there any additional any questions
oh and of course we do support
sb68 as we did work with senator bradley
to construct it
and then i've worked closely with
senator hennessey this session
to move this forward as well as the new
hampshire breastfeeding task force
um they have been established as a
non-profit
since well they're a grassroots
organization i think pretty recently are
uh considered a non-profit now uh but
they've been around since 1997 and
they've worked on legislation they've
worked with
businesses they've worked with hospitals
and moms et cetera
um to to further the the charge
of uh breastfeeding lactation and
assistance for mothers
in the state so i'll rest it there and
answer any questions that you might have
okay great
thank you uh representative van houghton
has a question thank you very much and
thank you for your testimony today
uh there has been some previous concern
in just the last few minutes about some
of the language in the bill
and i do recognize that some of the
language is not nebulous what is
reasonable for instance
and my reference to disability when
we're talking about pregnancy
and i i think i recognize that that
almost has to be
does this legislation should it pass
give you any kind of regulatory
authority
so that you will be able to interpret
how this wording
impacts those employers and employees
um thank you very much representative
van hoten for the question
um we have statutory authority uh as it
stands right now so we
are the enforcement agency for any
charge of discrimination
in new hampshire so i and i apologize i
neglected to share this
if there's a charge of discrimination in
any of those areas that i mentioned that
we have jurisdiction so
employment housing public accommodation
and k-12 education
you come to us first so um
k-12 is a little different uh just i'm
trying not to be too confusing or too
wordy here
you do have an opportunity to go to
court instead
but in employment um and housing
education customarily you come to us
first
so you don't go to court you file your
charge with us
and then we move forward from there so
with that being said
what the language is in sp 68
is the language that we use currently
to take any charges in this in this area
so what we've done is pull the language
from a couple of different spots
put it all into one so that it will be
in one area if if that makes sense and
to
your point it does have to be a little
vague because
as senator hennessey so eloquently
stated
one person's accommodation is not the
other person's accommodation
and um and what happens is the law of
law of unintended consequences
the more specific you are the more
people you potentially leave out so
you certainly don't want it to be too
vague but you also want
enough of an explanation so that
when someone is is looking something up
they have
a guidance they have parameters and
if i were pregnant and i i'm at my job
and i'm
working with the hr person
and it's now time for me to go on leave
because it's right before my due date
and then i'll be out on leave these are
some of the same terms that you would
use
in a business in an hr setting so it's
it's synonymous
so it helps everyone to say the same
thing and mean the same thing
i hope that answers your question it
does me a follow-up please
hear the question inquire thank you uh
what kinds of
consequences would be available for you
to meet out would it be corrective
action for the employer or
or what kinds of consequences or
directions are available to you
should you find culpability um yes thank
you for the question
um so a person uh will will come to us
and say
i've been wronged and they will share
what that is
if it meets um the if it's within our
jurisdiction
so jurisdiction is is a handful of
things
um as long as there it is within the
time frame
uh so there's a 180-day statute of
limitations from the last
action that that happened to the
individual
and if it's something that we cover so
if it's an
someone who's incarcerated for example
that would not be within our
jurisdiction
okay so for this example the um
the woman is saying i'm not being given
bathroom breaks
um and then they reach out to us
the first thing we do is have you
reached out to
your if it's a floor manager have you
talked to the manager above that person
have you reached out to hr
no i haven't okay thank you for letting
us know reach back out to the company
but
contact us and let us know if you're if
you don't get satisfaction
i reached out to my company they're not
they're refusing to do this
it's in writing somewhere that i can't
have these bathroom breaks okay
then we'll take your charge we take the
individual's charge
and then we um we dock at that
information
and then we send written information of
this charge of discrimination
to the business and they have an
opportunity to give a response to that
so let's say that we have found that
there has been discrimination that
the um that the woman went through the
proper chain of command
because that's important to request the
bathroom breaks that she
the additional bathroom breaks that she
was needing
she was denied that and so let's say
we've moved forward
and we have now found probable cause for
this
um for the individual who's filed this
charge of discrimination
so along the way there's mediation
that's possible
if um if the person if the business and
the individual
are willing to mediate um the woman may
say listen i i filed this so that i
could
get them to honor the what i need
but i don't really want to go through
all of this i just need bathroom breaks
and so if we're able to mediate
something and work it out
with the company then we're happy to do
that our mediation program is free
and we offer that for every
charge that makes sense to offer
mediation
so with that being said there could be
fines
the individual may have um financial
compensation that they're looking for if
they've lost wages if they've
lost time from work if they got fired or
something along those lines and so
those things are included in the
outcomes that they're looking for with
their charge
and of course when the investigator
investigates
one of those things that they may
suggest is
that there be a policy on pregnancy um
and um and and related
conditions so i hope that answered your
question
it does thank you and one more quick
follow-up okay
in your opinion then this legislation
would help to facilitate the fair and
reasonable process that you've just
documented for us
uh thank you very much for the follow-up
representative and yes
i in my in my opinion it would do that
yes
thank you okay representative abramson
has a question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i i guess on this if i'm if i'm a small
employer if i'm a small business
and i don't have the regulatory
consultants and the lawyer on retainer
and whatnot
how do i figure out what how much is an
undue hardship is it capped at ten
thousand dollars per employee
or or what is it um thank you
representative uh abramson for the
question so
undue hardship um it's it could be a
variety of things
so for example and let's use the example
that senator hennessey gave
if i worked in a warehouse i'm a
pregnant woman i work in a warehouse
and um what i'm requesting i you know my
doctor is saying
i can only lift uh 10 pounds whereas i
usually could lift
25 pounds so i go to the employer and i
say
i have a weight lifting restriction
and it's it's only 10 pounds um
and then the employer says oh okay well
we can put you we can change your shift
or
we can move you to a different area in
the warehouse to accommodate
the 10-pound lift or we can slightly
change
what you do during your regular shift
to accommodate you i may i might say
well thank you for that but i'm not
interested in doing that i'd much rather
work in this area over here where
there's no lifting at all or i'd
rather go to a different plant or
i would rather not work during this time
during the entire pregnancy so um or
i can come in but i won't lift anything
but if you could have this other
employee
do all of the lifting then i would much
rather prefer that
so here's the impasse
what the employee is is specifically
needing
is the weight restriction for the 10
pounds at per the doctor
what the employer has offered is several
ways
to accommodate that employee
that fall within what's what's available
for the employer
what they can afford to do and it
doesn't change anything
they're doing their portion to
accommodate the employee
the employee has decided that they don't
like the accommodation
and so they want someone else to fulfill
their
complete job description and
they either don't do their job
description at all or
go to a plant or somewhere completely
different that is not
that doesn't work for the employer so
all of this
is an interactive process they work
together
and so it could be an undue hardship
for the employer to hire someone
different to
offer overtime for someone else to do
the work
that this particular employee could have
done with the accommodation
so every workspace each employer is a
little different
and there are different things that
could be considered undo hardships
and how this really works is if the
employer has a question
although the commission is the
enforcement agency we're neutral
we are not attorneys that represent a
complainant
we also do not represent the respondent
if the
responding business has a question they
can call us
when they receive this information that
they've been charged with you know
discrimination they can call us and go i
don't really understand what's happening
here
can you explain this and well we have
documentation that says we offered this
as an accommodation
and the person refused it and now we're
being charged with discrimination
okay send that documentation in as your
response
and then we go through through it that
way so we don't offer legal advice
we can give people information on our
process and we work
to remain neutral in the process and to
um as much as you can
give information on the process without
it being representation
if that makes sense and i'm hoping that
i answered your question representative
uh follow-up further question may
inquire
okay if if i'm an employer and i have a
small
shop or a real estate job or a financial
industry or software development i need
to hire a specialist for one position
they're irreplaceable and i'm looking at
an applicant who is a woman of child
varying age
if i hire her what is
the most amount of money that this cost
me
for it to be a a new hardship under this
in other words what's the downside if i
hire this person
what's the worst amount of money that
i'm going to have to spend under this
under this bill okay and thank you for
the redirection
um and allow me to clarify so undue
hardship
is not necessarily um qualified by an
amount of money
so it's not just a dollar amount it's
what is it that you're having to do to
attempt to make this accommodation and
so
these are the variables that we use
every day
in general right so this is how we make
these determinations now
so it's not oh this business has
you know 20 employees and so an undue
hardship
is considered a ten thousand dollar or a
five thousand dollar
expenditure that's that's not what it is
it's
what is reasonable to accommodate this
individual
so um my my lawyer friends will
appreciate this if we all make widgets
and we're standing on the widget making
line
and this person has an accommodation
that they need and they need a stool to
sit on
the employer will can get them a very
comfortable stool
to sit on to use that as needed
on the widget making line but the
employee is saying
i don't want that one i want the solid
gold one
that when i clap it'll lift me up and
scoot me down
to the next side and throw away my trash
for me that's the one i want
well the employer is not under any
obligation
to purchase the solid gold can move with
clapping of hands chair
they are responsible for purchasing or
providing
something that is a reasonable uh
reasonably expected
to assist this person or to accommodate
them
to meet the needs of the job description
and and making sure that that person can
still
satisfy the essential elements of their
job
so let's say you have a warehouse job
that
is seasonal and it's around you know for
christmas and we need we need this we
need a lot of help in the warehouse
and is that the employer says
well all i call what i need you for is
the warehouse and if you can't lift then
you know i this is not going to work so
the all i can do is
is lay you off and the employee says
well i don't want to be laid off because
i'm going to get less money
you know you know my compensation can be
less i don't want to be laid off
um is the um how do you fall down on
that side
who who's who who gets the reasonable
compen you know
uh settlement right so thank you for the
question uh representative hunt
so ultimately all of this
is an interactive process so from
beginning to end
employee employer are working together
to find a reasonable solution to
whatever it is that the employee is
requesting so
when you have a reasonable accommodation
for anything
under the ada as well as as it relates
to
sb 68 if there is something that the
employer can provide or assist the
employee with
to allow them to continue the functions
of the job so
yes it's a warehouse job but what the
employer may have to do is be creative
is there a different area in the
warehouse that the person
can work for a period of time can the
shift be moved
so that maybe the morning shift has
lighter weight items whereas the
afternoon shift has heavier items
and so what the employee and the ploy
employer
are to do is to work collaboratively
to look for a solution if there is no
way for the employer to
maintain the employee's status
because there is no other shift it's
only an eight hour day and
we only have this there is no other
place then
as long as the in the
there is really no accommodation that
could meet
to allow the employee to meet the
essential functions of that position
if that person has to be let go because
it's it's not reasonable
to hire um you and
representative abramson to do my job
right so if you're paying me i have to
do my job
if i can do it with an accommodation
great and it's usually
only for a limited amount of time anyway
right
and so if there is no way
and that person has to be furloughed or
something and sometimes you may do a
well we need to lay you off for you know
six months
or three months or whatever but we want
you to come back because there just
isn't anything then that could be and
that person may feel that they are wrong
but it's something to remember that
every wrong isn't actionable
if the employer has followed the letter
of the law
if they have worked collaboratively with
the employee
to look for a reasonable solution and
there just
isn't one to be found if that person
must be furloughed
they're a great employee and you want
them to stay with you you just don't
have anything for now
then that's just that's how that works
unfortunately nothing is perfect right
so and then to follow up on uh
representative abramson's previous
questions
um because it's always been said that
that employers
generally don't hire women because
they're because they are child bearing
and
did or do you fear at all that this is
going to
um accelerate that or accentuate that
that this be a temptation for employers
not to hire
women simply because they're fearful of
having to go through this process
to have to defend why they you know
they can't keep this person while
they're pregnant
um and thank you representative hunt for
the follow-up so
what's in sb 68 is the way that the
commission operates
to this day so this does not change
how we do business as it were so
sp 68 is no different than how we've
been operating with employers in the
state
for 50 plus years so there should be no
expectation
that an employer would do something
adverse
based on the language in sb68 you could
go to our website now
and find this language um
and if you look at any cases that we um
have published on our website that
deal with pregnancy and we don't have a
lot of those so that's that's a good
sign
uh that we don't have a lot um but that
being said
there there should be no expectation
that employers would
would be um prone to
being less receptive
to women of child bearing age
as the in in the way that they are now
so
there there should be no concern with
that we aren't concerned
that it would create uh some some
adverse action towards uh pregnant women
or um women in the age group
of pregnancy and that's changed now we
have a 57 year old that recently gave
birth in new hampshire
so being a teacher too right child
bearing age is a is a different thing
now
okay uh representative johnson has a
question
thank you for taking my question so my
concern is
that if this really isn't an issue and
you know i've worked for many different
businesses from small but large
if well if the employers are already
working with their employees
why do we need a law on the books
telling them what to do when they're
already doing it and if it's already
being
work you know handled and worked with
and communicated
and you know collaborative with the
employee and employee
employers and the employees why do we
need a law
telling them how to what to do what
they're already doing
representative johnson thank you very
much for the question so
um you you have new employers that start
all the time
um and you have new employees that begin
um all the time correct and you also
have people who've never been pregnant
before that will become pregnant and so
these could be concerns
so even though overall
we've had very positive
uh outcomes um we've
not had a plethora of pregnancy
cases it doesn't hurt to codify this
into law so that it's very clear in one
area
of our statute as it relates to
pregnancy
um we want to make sure that it's very
clear
and concise and easy to find
uh is there any other questions for
representative emerson um
i hope you have one question well it was
actually more of a
verifying my remarks um i'm i'm trying
to break the glass ceiling so i
for for the next generation of women i
understand
uh mr chair you know the factory floor
making widgets and having to put a chair
what about
a young woman who wants to become junior
vice president
or a medical specialist or a database
specialist or something where it's just
one position in that company especially
for small businesses we only have one
person in that position
it's very hard to make accommodations
for that and it it it
feels like this build away it's written
with the uncertainty
um as is that uh that this would just be
yet another obstacle for women who are
trying to move up into a position in a
company where there's only that just
that one position
i mean that that's that's why i'm saying
is there some way we can rewrite this
so that this doesn't put an undue burden
on them
or on their employer or a small business
on new startups
that's why i'm thinking you know maybe
put a cap on it so it's something that's
certain
five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars obviously that they could
accommodate with
the chair or or adjusting their schedule
or bathroom breaks
but if they can have an actual dollar
figure of some kind
then they know this is the limit of how
much of a burden this is going to place
on the company
they can calculate it and they can make
that decision whether they're retiring
or promoting
representative hum if i may respond to
that certainly
okay thank you and i i really do
appreciate your concerns uh
representative abramson
i i i hear what you're saying the
difficulty with
doing something along those lines um
is that every accommodation
is not something that's financial so
it may not entail um hi
it may not entail uh providing a
financial
incentive or or purchasing an
item it it could be a 20 chair
it could be just allowing more bathroom
breaks
it could be that the person
may need a longer lunch period
because after they eat they have to you
know they need to take a rest or
something
because there's some other physical
situation so
those are things that don't require
money and
and a large amount of these things are
things that
that don't require money at all um so
in putting in something a financial
piece
what it it it opens up an area that
isn't
really necessary um and i
under i i promise you i hear your
concerns because you're wanting to make
sure
that a business can understand in a
financial way what a reasonable
accommodation is
however a large majority of reasonable
accommodations
may not require money at all so
it leaves it to the commission as we
are the enforcement agency to under to
um to extrapolate what reasonable
is um and as senator hennessey said you
know each person's reasonable is a
little different or each person's
request is a little different
one person's reasonable accommodation is
literally just a stool to sit on or
uh extra bathroom breaks someone else is
reasonable
is that they need an office that's
closer to the elevator
so it doesn't mean that a business is
expected to purchase
or build out a new office but what
can we empty out this room clean it up
and make this the office
for for that particular employee so what
it does by
not putting a dollar amount it allow it
gives the commission
flexibility to to entertain
what is reasonable what is a reasonable
standard with this particular situation
because
if i am you know for example if i'm an
unreasonable employee
and there's a dollar amount put on there
then says well i'm only asking for
something that's two thousand dollars
it's not ten and that's the limit so you
should be able to grant this
but that two thousand dollar request
might not financially let's say that
might not be unreasonable but what
they're asking for
is unreasonable when they were offered
something that was
perfectly reasonable but because it
wasn't what the
employee wanted we don't we don't judge
reasonableness by
what i what i would prefer you know of
course i'd prefer an easy boy lounge
chair
but the business is not required to
provide that for me
they're pro they're required to provide
a
reasonable accommodation a comfortable
chair for which i need to sit
they're not required to purchase a
twelve hundred or
two thousand dollar chair and so by and
i
again i completely understand what
you're asking however by
adding dollar amounts in there i think
we start
to change the conversation and
we've not had to my recollection and i
can double check this and certainly get
back to you
we've not had a reasonable accommodation
in a pregnancy case where there was some
huge
dollar amount i mean it's usually small
things that are needed
and some cases are solved with mediation
once the small and a lot of times just
small businesses that just aren't sure
what they're supposed to do
so through conversation they understand
oh okay well i can do this or i should
do this
and we assist in making that clear
representative patrick uh do you have a
question
it's a very it's a it's a very it's a
would you believe
well i just realized that i i screwed up
there were two
people who were in opposition to the
bill and i somehow missed them
um so uh maybe we should hear from them
uh but let you does you want to go ahead
with your would you believe
uh mrs nalakai would you believe i now
have a better understanding
of reasonableness that was my main
question when i went through this and
when you started
but now i have a much better
understanding
of reasonables thank you very much for
your testimony
welcome you're welcome so uh yeah so is
sarah brahman
or kate frederick are you guys uh do you
guys still want to speak i see that you
were in opposition to the bill so just
raise your hand if you would like to
speak
okay um i i can't believe i did this but
[Music]
um
is an imperfect science okay so kate
frederick
and you just have to unmute yourself i
am sorry i that i thought i had
everything and i
i apologize no worries i'm i'm still
available if there are any other
questions or if there's some redirection
that's needed thank you
great yes so go ahead ms frederick
hi chairman hunt it's so good to see you
again i wish i was in the
hearing committee room with you all um
my name is kate frederick and
i am opposing this bill because i think
it's too vague and i think it will cause
a lot of confusion
for employers to know what they're
supposed to do
and what they don't have to do and i
think it'll cause conflict for employees
who think they have a right but maybe
don't or have a right
but can't prove it because everything's
too big
um i am
a current student of vermont law school
i also attend classes at dartmouth's
medical school and public health
towards my law degree
i experienced pregnancy discrimination
while i worked as a child support
officer in conway new hampshire
for the state of new hampshire i had
two medical conditions gestational
diabetes which is diabetes while you're
pregnant
caused by pregnancy hormones i had a
severe case
and i required four
shots of insulin a day self-administered
multiple finger pricks to test my blood
sugar
exercise after i ate to bring down my
blood sugar levels
i was also anemic i had low iron levels
which made me extremely
tired
and i experienced pregnancy
discrimination from my supervisor who
was a woman
who had had a child and i reported her
i was harassed on the job i was
i received nasty comments from my
supervisor
um that led to further discrimination
after i had
my baby
so i do see the need for more specific
language for what
reasonable accommodations are what
undo hardship is and
what reasonable means so i
submitted a report that i co-authored
um to you all by email
i want to refer you to page 25.
this really starts on page 24 but page
discusses the term undo hardship
and i have a full page
to define what undo hardship is how it
is applied
how employers can use it what
calculations they use
etc so i would refer you to that page
when you're making your decision
um it basically looks at
the budget of the employer and they
compare it to the accommodation that is
requested
there are several caveats in there about
how you can't use undo hardship for
certain situations and scenarios
i would also like to refer you to page
letter f to find reasonable
accommodation i think just saying
reasonable
is terrible i think you need to use an
actual definition
so i provided you with the one from the
american
with disabilities act and as
director malachi explained in 354-a
pregnancy is considered a temporary
disability
in new hampshire in other states
pregnancy is not
an automatic disability but in new
hampshire it is
so this offers the definition of
reasonable accommodation from
the american with disabilities act it
also
provides a definition through the us
department of justice
and it also provides a separate
definition under the federal
nursing mothers provision
that is enforced by the united states
department of labor
and that's relevant because
the federal law of the pregnancy
discrimination act
is what the state law
has to also meet you can't create a law
a state law that has less provisions
less protective provisions
than the federal law um
i think probably attorney sarah braffman
can
explain additional legal points um so i
don't want to take up too much of your
time
um i would suggest the following
i have talked to the governor's office
i spoke with elliot gould i requested
instead of this bill i requested
that the governor establish a governor's
council
on pregnancy and lactation
discrimination in the workplace
explicitly and that
this bill could be amended by that
council
and it would have the voices of
employers it would have the voices of
the administrative agencies involved
including the human rights commission it
would have the voices of
employees who have experienced
discrimination in the workplace
that have exact examples
um and i i think that we could really
turn out a better product
thank you okay thank you uh
representative abramson has a question
can you hear me yes we can um i have
essentially the same question i'm an
employer
and i'm facing this this mandate and at
the same time i'm
i'm trying to hire from pooled employees
uh for a for a one-off position whether
it's
management position or or medical
specialist or something else
if i'm facing this law and
but some of the candidates are are women
of childbearing age
are they going to have a harder time
totally
and chairman hunt actually asked me this
question several years ago i forgot to
mention my legislative history is that
i'm the woman that has
submitted the original language for the
previous seven bills
related to pregnancy and lactation
um so yes chairman
had asked me this question early on and
i had a similar answer
you know what employers may take this
opportunity
very few but some may take this
opportunity to discriminate
and then people will miss out on jobs
and then maybe they'll have a legal
cause of action afterwards that'll get
settled 10 years down the line
[Music]
my answer back then also was what i'm
going to say now
the pregnancy discrimination act is
already a law that's intended to
prevent this type of discrimination
it makes it discriminatory to not hire
somebody based on gender
pregnancy status etc and
with a good faith effort we you know we
believe that i believe that
most employers attempt to
follow the law and are not intending to
intentionally disregard the law
for those reasons all
uh we're getting tight on time so sir go
ahead
real quick um is it is it possible to
put into this bill some kind of dollar
amount with a thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars per employee
you don't just have you know one company
is
the commissioner commission might
one year they allow somebody just one
company to do
nothing and another one you've got a
billion
billion dollars sure
i mean anything is possible i i think i
would defer to
director malachi on that she's the one
that is in charge of enforcing
the statute um what i would suggest
is because every employer has a
different
budget and salary that perhaps a ratio
could be more efficient and clear
but if there were a governor's council
established i think that would be
a high priority to suss out
uh we do have one more question here
representative bartlett
i'd like to ask a question thank you mr
chair so let me get
let me get this straight mr frederick
you've been here seven times before
trying to get
a bill passed um you don't like this
bill
you want a a study commission to make it
perfect
and you're willing to continue to allow
this to
um not be on the books
and that's okay with you because you
don't like this one
those words i don't think that's an
accurate representation
of my intent as director malachi
said they've already been doing this
since they were established this bill
doesn't create any new
provisions or any new accommodations
employers are already required to
provide accommodations
under the new hampshire disability law
i think hill doesn't do anything new it
doesn't offer anything
new it doesn't make anything more clear
i i certainly appreciate that it is
highly counter-intuitive that i would be
opposing this bill
um i'm extremely passionate about
advocating for pregnancy
and breastfeeding rights but i if there
were amendments to the bill i would
support it
thank you for your question okay we
thank you very much for your testimony
uh i will call in sarah rafman
thank you representative hunt and um
thank you to the committee for allowing
me to testify today
my name is sarah brafman and i am an
attorney and senior policy counsel at a
better balance
we are a leading advocacy organization
and our expert
specifically in workplace pregnancy
accommodations
we've assisted municipal state and the
federal government
on the issue of pregnancy accommodations
we've helped draft we've helped
implement we've helped enforce new laws
there are now 30 states that have
greater protections for pregnant workers
in need of accommodation
and i will say in new hampshire we we
run a free legal helpline as well where
workers from around the country call us
with questions and we do hear from
workers in new hampshire who are
pregnant and struggling to get
accommodations
just to the question of whether this is
an issue or not we do hear from new
hampshire workers and
i consulted with my colleagues just
before this um
and we have in you know just the past
um recent recent past hurt from three
new hampshire workers around this issue
specifically
and i really want to thank senator
hennessey
for lifting up this issue for her deep
commitment to pregnant workers
and the same goes for the commission as
well we've actually spoken with the
commission about this bill
um and i think the intent is good you
heard senator hennessy say
to one of the questions our intent is
that reasonable accommodations would be
available
even if the pregnant worker doesn't have
a disability but the
a temporary physical disability is only
for a leave of absence
but the issue is we really have concerns
that the way the bill is drafted won't
be
interpreted to read that intent into the
bill
and that's for a couple of reasons so
number one is that
the way the bill is drafted it could
look like reasonable accommodations
is only available for those with
temporary physical disabilities
and the reason why that's a problem is
because
for many pregnant workers and the
examples that senator hennessy gave
needing a water bottle on a job needing
a bathroom break
pregnant workers often don't need that
because they have a disability
but they need that to prevent a
disability from arising
so a lot of women will go to the doctor
and their doctor will say
please don't lift over 50 pounds because
that could cause a complication
and that could lead to miscarriage
please drink a lot of water because if
you don't drink water you will get
dehydrated
and that could lead to a uti so it's not
that they
currently have a disability but that
they need an accommodation to prevent
the disability
and we know that even well-intended
agency interpretation can lead to
problems so maryland is a good example
in maryland they passed a law that said
reasonable accommodations for pregnant
workers with disabilities
the agency had a very broad
interpretation of that
even things that might not rise to the
level of disability under federal law
could
meet the maryland could meet the
maryland standard under that statute
but three years later a court came down
and courts don't have to follow
agency interpretation and the court said
well this pregnant worker
doesn't have a disability in the more
traditional sense of the word right like
having a complication
that rises to the level of disability
and so
she doesn't get the accommodation and
then there's the
sort of third problem which is that most
workers and most workers
we hear from will never go to an agency
they will never bring a case in court
and all they have to go on is the
employer and employee relationship
and employers are going to see in the
statute that a pregnant worker
has to have a disability in order to
receive an accommodation
and i'll say that pregnant that
employers as well have been wanting
clarity in the law
around when do i have to provide an
accommodation and when don't i have to
provide an accommodation
and that's why the us chamber of
commerce is supporting
a federal fix around pregnancy
accommodations that's why we've had
business support in other states
around making sure to say that pregnancy
is not a disability
very very clearly in the statutes so
that we don't have problems
and the same goes if the commission if
there's a change in administration and
there's a new agency
they might not take the same
interpretation and you have
their the commission really i think is
very dedicated to making sure pregnant
women can
get the accommodations that they need
but it's if there's a way to slightly
tweak
the statute and to tweak the legislation
to make it abundantly clear
that a pregnant worker doesn't have to
have a disability you know we would
we think that would really take it to
the next step and there's very simple
ways of doing this so right now
the statute reasonable accommodation
statute
354 a2 in the definitions there's a
definition of reasonable accommodation
there's a definition of undue hardship
and the definition of reasonable
accommodation
says that it must be an individual with
a disability
and so we propose a much
shorter very succinct definition to go
into this statute into this bill itself
in 354 a7
to say for the purposes of this
subsection the term reasonable
accommodation means
any change or modification in the work
environment
or the normal course of business and to
leave in place
the undue hardship standard around um
that's
that's the same in the statute and to
your point representative abramson
we do have an undue hardship standard
already in the new hampshire code
that has four factors that employers
have to meet
and i do worry a little bit if we go in
and change the undue hardship standard
for pregnancy
that we're putting pregnant workers at a
disadvantage over workers with
disability because we don't have a cap
on the number figure for disa for
accommodations for disability
but we but if we put in a cap for
pregnancy we run into potential problems
and
potential problems yeah that i think
could could result for employers
honestly if they're
you know providing accommodations for
disabilities on one hand but the under
hardship standard is different but
here um it's not for pregnant workers
and then the other tweak that we would
suggest
is really just adding a couple commas
and one and a couple words
which is to say an employer shall
provide reasonable accommodations
comma including permitting a female
employee to take a leave of absence
for the period of temporary physic
physical disability
comma for the the known limitations
resulting from pregnancy childbirth or
related medical conditions
and by putting into the statute known
limitations
then we are making clear that for
accommodations
it does not need to rise for to the
level of disability but that for the
leave of absence
you would still need a period of
temporary physical disability
and the last thing i'll say um and i'm
happy to take questions and and happy to
have a colloquy with miss malachi as
well
is that the the statute does say
for and i'm sorry i'm just going to pull
it up because i don't want to quote
without being prepared but it says for
all other employment related purposes
including receipt of benefits under
fringe benefit programs
pregnancy childbirth and related medical
conditions shall be considered temporary
disabilities so
my understanding is that the commission
is interpreting pregnancy
to mean a temporary physical disability
but the statute goes on to say
affected by pregnancy childbirth-related
medical conditions shall be treated in
the same manner as
any employee affected by any other
temporary disability
and that language really comes from the
pregnancy discrimination act
where in order to get accommodations you
need to compare yourself to another
employee who's getting accommodations
but what we're trying to do here and
what the pregnancy accommodation laws
around the country
are trying to do that that have already
been enacted is to take out that
comparator standard
and to make very clear you just have to
have to have known limitations
and you have to engage in this
interactive process to get the
reasonable accommodation
and then if it's an undue hardship then
they don't need to provide that
and i'm happy to go into how other
states have kind of
used this language some states have used
the term known limitations
that's what we're moving towards in the
federal legislation so if state and
federal
are aligned you know known limitations
is what we're suggesting
here so that they would align if that
bill passes but
other states you know massachusetts
vermont they use pregnancy-related
conditions so they don't use
no limitation but they use
pregnancy-related condition
um so that's an option um other states
use
medical need instead of disability so
there's an array of options
and they really are what we're
suggesting is a slight tweak
to it to the bill which i think would um
really align with what senator hennessey
is trying to do and i think we can align
the really amazing intent that's here
with the language itself that's in the
bill
and and harmonize them um so i'll stop
there and
i'm happy to take questions um i'm also
happy to talk about one of the recent
cases
in new hampshire where a court did find
that a pregnancy that pregnancy was a
disability
which kind of took a different approach
than the commission does so it shows how
courts
really kind of follow their own path and
that's why having clarity in the statute
itself is incredibly important
thank you great thank you
um so we do have
the question representative mclaren
thank you mr chairman
um mrs braffman you sound extremely
up on this whole thing um
i personally would hate to be in a
position that i would vote against this
bill
hypothetically could you write a
amendment could you personally write an
amendment
that covers what you're talking about
that i could sponsor and add to the bill
that would uh would make this bill
passable by all
again i would hate to be in a position
where
um they don't know that it doesn't go
far enough
and therefore i'm voting against it uh
that's a terrible position to be in
could you do that yes and it's
it's ready to go so i'm happy to email
it to
representative hunt as we speak um
it's very i know that we want to
streamline it i think
it really puts it in a place where it's
aligned with senator hennessey and with
miss malachi and i will say
i know and we did testify in the senate
and that i
i completely understand i'm not from new
hampshire i own that
but we have spoken to the aclu of new
hampshire we have spoken to moms rising
in new hampshire they have heard these
concerns as well
um i spoke with executive director of
the aclu of new hampshire devin chaffee
she couldn't be here today just because
of a conflict but she
is in support of the amendment the aclu
is in support of this amendment
um and would like to have further
conversation so i'm not here
trying to say let's not pass this bill i
want i
we would love to see this bill pass we
just want to see it pass in the right
way
and if we could have these discussions
to to introduce this amendment and put
this in and make it
a strong the strong bill that it could
be we want to get there with you
but i will say there have been times
when you know we are here to support
pregnant workers we want clarity that is
the main thrust of our organization but
when
when the bills don't fulfill their
intent and
when the policy itself is something
we're concerned about
we think we need to take a pause and
give it a little bit more of a look and
when new hampshire organizations are
saying that as well
we think you know making sure that we
can take the time that
you know ms chafee said she would really
love to have a conversation with miss
malachi
about this and talk through this
amendment um same goes for
christina d'alessandro from mom's rising
as well
in new hampshire to talk this through i
think it bears a little bit more time
to try to get us all on the same page
and making sure that it works best
because
we're we are going to be the ones on the
ground hearing from workers in new
hampshire
and still struggling with with a law
that isn't that isn't clear
and that isn't clear for employers
either so i'd be happy
to to share that with you representative
um so that you can introduce that
amendment
thank you very much representative van
houghton has a question
yes thank you very much and thank you
for your testimony i have had a chance
to take a look at some of your
suggestions
prior to your testimony and my only
question right now is did you present
these ideas to the senate
prior to their voting we did we
presented them and senator whitley
um put in an amendment it was we did not
have a lot of time to talk with the
commission about it and so it was a bit
more of a rushed process
in doing that i will say we also this
amendment that you were sent
representative
was even trying to streamline more so
than we did in the senate to make
to make sure that we're we're not here
trying to
do a whole lot we are here to try to
fulfill the intent of senator hennessey
of the commission um and and trying to
make it even more streamlined
than that but yes we raised them
for the senate as well and
representative abramson
has a question thanks representative
manhattan
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh
so i'm not saying redefine undue
hardship just for this
particular section this particular
provision
what i'm saying is why not just delete
that whole phrase where it starts with
on line nine
unless such employer can demonstrate
that the accommodation would impose an
undue hardship on the operation of the
employer's business
and just set a clear predictable cap i
don't know a thousand dollars per
employee or ten thousand dollars
or some amount where it's predictable
where the employer
knows what's the worst case scenario
that they might be
hit with so if the accommodations being
requested could cost
20 or 30 000 in overtime or it could
cost them
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars in structural change in
their business can we just put that
okay so you you've asked this question
multiple times and i think that she
uh the previous uh testifier did say to
you that it needs to be some kind of
ratio because
a thousand dollars to a small you know
two-person operation is a lot different
than a thousand dollars to a company
that has 500 employees
so 28 certain you know
my suggestion is a thousand dollars per
employee
or ten thousand dollars per employee no
more than that amount
per employee so if you have the factory
and there are five people who become
pregnant you can buy
you can buy five chairs that you keep
around for a very large factory
versus a small shop that has two
employees where it becomes impossible
for them to do it the cost might be too
high for them
i will say if i if i may represent one
um
that the undue hardship standard exists
in every bill every law that we now have
on this and it has not come up as
an issue so i i fully respect the
wanting clarity but on this particular
issue i think
we are trying to have an individualized
process between
employer and employee and in a sense
that putting that cap on can
almost impede that individualized
process that they can undergo which i
i think miss malachi was was emphasizing
as well
and again you have this you have the
standard in place
already for 30 years from the americans
disabilities act
around undue hardship so certainly there
are regulations and maybe
it bears giving hypotheticals and
examples of what could constitute an
undue hardship
and i'm you know we'd certainly be in
favor of that you know if it's a small
employer
to kind of tease out but i think that
that is better served
for for a regulatory function than it is
for bearing it out in the statute itself
because we're talking about an
individualized process
and because you have a multiple factor
test already in the statute
okay uh representative ammon has a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
could you tell us where you're located
and what your nexus is with the state of
new hampshire
thank you sure i am currently located in
washington dc
um we have offices in we're
headquartered in new york city we have
offices in washington dc
nashville and denver colorado um we
are not based in new hampshire um but we
like i mentioned
we run a free legal helpline and
we hear from workers around the country
who are having issues
around getting accommodations in the
workplace and so we have
heard from workers in new hampshire and
i
i know of three specifically who have
called us
in the recent past around issues of
needing pregnancy accommodations in the
workplace and not being able to get
those accommodations
and so again i want to emphasize i know
i'm not from new hampshire but we are
speaking with organizations in new
hampshire the aclu of new hampshire
is you know is supportive of this
amendment the
the um moms rising based in new
hampshire
um is supportive and under understanding
of these concerns
and so i i totally
want to recognize that but what i can
say is we are
we are expert in this issue you know i'm
not speaking to any of the other issues
that are here today but this is an issue
where
we are very much in the weeds on it we
very much
care about every single pregnant woman
pregnant worker who needs an
accommodation is able to get one we know
that there are some workers in new
hampshire
that are not able to and we want to be
here to support them
no matter where we are in the country
uh great thank you very much um uh
um miss malachi i did promise you that
you would have the last
oh wait a minute representative michael
here you have another question for
mr yes thank you mr chairman
um while you were talking i'm reading
through some of my
messages and i've got a message by
a mr uh what's his name
axelman and he says that uh
if he were to start a business he would
not hire woman
because of this if this law went into
effect
if i understood you to say earlier what
he's saying is basically illegal
is that correct that's correct so the
pregnancy discrimination act
under federal law and new hampshire law
itself
it is illegal to not hire a woman
just because she is pregnant um that was
made clear in 1978
um and i think you know there's a lot of
i've heard some discussion
about well if we pass this law will that
also um
lead to employers not hiring pregnant
women because they're concerned they
could need accommodations
so the first thing is that this actually
is a workforce retention issue
we are trying to make sure that women
can stay healthy and working women
you know 88 of women who are working
stay through their third trimester
women want and need to keep working
during their pregnancies
but often a small needing a small
accommodation can lead to their being
pushed out of the workforce
this is actually a way to keep women in
the workforce and attached to the
workforce and that's why
the bill has had such bipartisan support
in so many places
and the second piece is that you know
pregnancy
accommodations are often very small and
they you know it we're talking about
very minor things
but i think there is a social aspect to
it you know when
when the pregnancy discrimination act
passed i think a lot of
employers said well now that the
pregnancy discrimination act exists
it's going to lead to pregnant you know
to employers being scared to hire
pregnant women because we're nervous
about discrimination
and that certainly did not come to bear
women have are in the workforce in
record numbers today and the same
continues and
by providing accommodations i think
we're going to see a more harmonious
workplace where pregnant women can stay
attached to the workforce while they're
pregnant and
continue to contribute to their
workplaces
so i just think it's it's a question we
hear but it's not a question that comes
to bear
um just a quick comment on that i would
suggest that all of you
uh representatives got this uh email
from
elliot uh axelman uh i find it a very
uh uh discouraging comment from him
uh please take a read thank you and i
think it shows why this law is needed
because
there you know a lot of employers are
incredibly wonderful
and i know a lot of members might be
employers themselves and a lot of
employers are already doing this
but for some this clarity and the law
about
what we as a society believe is
important and from a legal standpoint
is important for those you know few
employers that
that need that clarity as well
okay so i see that mr axelman has raised
his hand he did not actually sign up to
speak i was going to represent have my
mountain malachi to finish up and we
are extremely late so we're cutting into
our lunch hour
so all i can do is i being respectful i
will let people testify mr axeman but
you better be brief because i might just
cut you right off
so i will promote you and
miss malachi i will allow you to wrap it
up but i hope you can also be brief when
we do this because we
otherwise we could just keep doing this
and
so go ahead mr ag uh oh no i didn't it
didn't
go oh there he goes are you up
uh yeah there you go just you have to
unmute yourself
all right sorry it looks like it kicked
me out a minute ago can you hear me now
yes all right sorry all right uh sorry
for not signing up i signed up for
senate bill
69 but it looks like this one was
running late so i'm here too but there's
similar bills i can testify once for
both
as i said in the email these bills make
women
less employable i know that one of the
representatives read my email and said
that i sound bigoted i'm sorry
um i don't hate women i love women i'm
married to one i have three sisters a
mother and plenty of other
female relatives i want the best for
women my
wife is hopefully soon to be pregnant
and she is employed
this bill would make her a less
attractive employee
it would make her from an asset into a
liability which makes her less likely to
be employed and remain employed
the basic rules of economics cannot be
manipulated if a woman costs more
to employ they are less likely to be
employed
as i said in in my email in the
testimony
if it costs me twice as much to employ a
woman i'm going to hire
a male for that same job is that illegal
yes someone mentioned that's probably
illegal throw me in jail so be it
you can't manipulate the market and the
basic rules of the world
if you make women have accommodations go
with them
or if you made males have accommodations
if there were a bill that
max proposed that made it a law for you
to supply
beautiful 25 year old masseuses every
three hours for every male employee
that would make male employees more
expensive to employ you would make them
liabilities
that would not get jobs and it would be
a bad bill and i would oppose it it's
not about sexism or feminism
i think it's very inappropriate to make
it about feminism or sexism
this is the opposite this bill makes
women
harder to employ and and that's my big
point i'll be briefing on there thank
you
great uh does this mean you won't have
to testify on the next bill
no they're similar enough that i think
that this same uh reasoning applies to
both thank you
okay so yes you you don't have to
testify great thank you
uh all right um all right
miss malachi why don't you wrap it up
for us please
um i have a question
i mean i i okay is it really that
vitally this question is really gonna
be earth-shattering and everybody's
gonna have a whole new insight here
yes okay go ahead good question
what's that this is a really brilliant
creative question
how much if this bill passes
as written and you hire a woman of child
bearing age
what is the maximum amount that you may
have to spend
to make those accommodations based on
the wording that's there
the way i've understand this bill is is
that
what they're most concerned is process
it's not about the dollar amount of it
it's about the process
did the company spend the time trying
their best
to accommodate the the pregnant woman
if they did if they did everything
possible to accommodate and they have
convinced the commission
that they did a good job of process and
that they really did everything possible
to bend over backwards to try to find a
solution
and but at the end of the day they say
this is just not going to work
that the commission will not cost them
you know will not charge them they will
not have to pay
a dime as long as they did
their process as long as they convinced
the commission that they
did everything in their power to try to
find a solution
okay all right so miss malachi
did i wrap it up for you did i say
everything you need to say or would you
like to switch it anymore
what you all said uh just two two very
quick points um
to to wrap it up and um thank you very
much for allowing me to do that um i
appreciate the testimony that's been
given
uh all of it um and
uh to um to several points that were
were made uh previously um
and i think actually attorney brachman
may have covered this but just to
put a finer point on it several of the
definitions i think
people were questioning reasonable
accommodation
as well as undue hardship and those
elements are defined currently in our
statute which is what we would use so
even though this particular bill is is
specific to pregnancy
um in in one area of our statute
the definitions are clearly stated
and those are the things that we're
using so we also use precedent
um to to make decisions and um
and we use so with how we
operate um certainly we are the
enforcement agency
but when we have a question on
redefining something or a different
entire a possible
additional interpretation of something
we go to the ag's office
and that's the arbiter of our state
statutes period
end of story and so we have a
very familial relationship with the ag's
office and we use our
the attorney that is provided for us all
the time
in so much as we have monthly meetings
to make sure
that we are doing our best to interpret
interpret the law
uh in the broadest sense to allow
individuals who may have a charge to be
able to bring a charge
of uh discrimination so that we don't
leave anyone out so that no one's rights
are violated or
or hampered um i
i think there's a bit of confusion and i
appreciate what
attorney brachman has stated and we have
met before
the the groups that that
a better balance have met with although
they're in new hampshire
their national organizations the new
hampshire
grassroots organization that has been
dealing with this issue
for decades since 1997 is the new
hampshire breastfeeding task force they
were not included in
in some of those meetings and the
commission has met with them on other
occasions
and uh to an earlier point um i i
regarding an amendment i don't think any
additional amendments are necessary
um for a variety of reasons which i
won't go into but one of which was
relative to um a council
or a um a group
that could or an advisory council that
could
contemplate these issues on a consistent
basis
um that has already been done it was um
there were two different uh bills sb 488
which was in 2016
and sb 478 which was in 2018 and
both of those bills dealt with creating
an
advisory council which ms fredricks was
a member of
and participated in uh in some degree
with some of the in terms of the
meetings and there was a wide variety
of stakeholders there were mothers state
agencies
someone an attorney representing
appointed by the commission
you had people from dhhs you had people
from the business
community so there was a wide variety of
stakeholders
and from that that council
actually sb69 which we'll eventually get
to
was created um and so there's wide
um there there's wide uh
uh con uh i can't think of the word now
but
uh um a lot of people pull together to
to
pull to to come up with the um
the bill that the further the sp 69 that
we're going to discuss
i apologize a little flustered at the
moment um
part of the confusion is that in new
york
and quite a few other states you may as
a person who's been discriminated
against
you may go to court first
and or you might go to a commission like
ours
like ours in new hampshire you come to
us first you do not go to court first
so we are able to interpret
and give deference to people who are
filing
a charge of discrimination for
themselves even if they're represented
but we really work to make sure that
someone who's not represented has a full
understanding of
of what remedies are available to them
so
using a court interpretation although
could be relevant at some point
if a person is been if the person who
files the charge
gets prop if there's probable cause
that's found
then that individual can then remove it
from us
and take it to court or they can remain
with us and go through a hearing
after probable cause is found just like
if the business wants to remove it to
court and try it there
but it's important to note that although
court
decisions are relevant they do not have
bearing
as to how the commission would follow a
charge through
so you have to based on state tax
statute
file a charge of discrimination with us
first
and um and it's good to know from
attorney brachman that there
have been some calls that were made to
them i would
i would appreciate if those uh
individuals and i would love to work
even more
closely with the better balance if those
individuals had been referred to the
commission
we might have either been able to file a
charge on their behalf
or to intervene to assist those
individuals
because of how state law is stated
a better balance they can maybe talk to
the employer but they cannot file a
charge
on that individual's behalf they have to
come to us first
so it would be i think even more
productive if we were more collaborative
on that and and we could assist those
those new hampshire
individuals in their concerns or issues
that they might be having so without us
knowing about them
there's nothing that we can do um and so
i would leave it there and hope that we
can conclude testimony on
sb69 and then move on exceeding on sb68
and then move on to sb69 okay so so i'm
sorry
uh rep rapping
we can't have this going back and forth
okay so uh and i did promise her that
i'd give her the last word i
you know so i i screwed up but at this
point let's let's just get on to the
next spell i think we all pretty much
have
got got through this one so i thank you
uh thank you all
uh and i will close the public hearing
and
uh say that there were 91 people in
support
five opposed and one neutral okay
uh and better late than never uh senator
whitney i'm sorry
about this delay i uh um
things got a little more complicated
than i expected um
so uh good still morning good morning
good morning thank you mr chair and
hello members of the committee
for the record my name is becky whitley
and i'm honored to serve new hampshire
senate district 15
which includes the wonderful communities
of concord penacook
henniker hopkinton and warner as a
working
mother of a young child and a former
nursing mother
i'm proud to appear before you today to
introduce senate bill
69. many working families know
that working and having a family has
never been
so difficult stagnant incomes and
outdated workplace practices continue to
pit being apparent
against having a career furthermore
the global pandemic has
disproportionately impacted
working mothers and women of color in
new hampshire across the country as well
and we've seen women leaving the
workforce during the last year because
they simply cannot meet all the demands
placed on them
we need to do more to support working
mothers senate bill 69
does this by requiring certain employers
in a flexible manner to provide access
to a sufficient space and a reasonable
break period
for nursing mothers to express milk
during working hours
this bill builds on years of work by
senator martha fuller clark
and an incredibly strong and responsive
coalition
that was mentioned before of
stakeholders who work together to come
up with
a new hampshire solution to support
women in the workplace
that's the bill that you will hear today
so specifically this
bill fills the coverage gap for working
women
who were and continue to be excluded
from the 2010
federal law break time for nursing
mothers
this federal law was an incredibly
important first step
but nearly one and four women of child
bearing age are not covered by the
federal law
32 states have already passed
legislation to bridge the gap in the
federal law
to cover more nursing mothers and
provide
expanded protections and now it's new
hampshire's turn
this bill is a win-win solution for the
granite state because it benefits babies
working mothers businesses and our
economy
while the health benefits are well of
nursing are well known and there are
others to testify to those health
benefits
returning to work and we know that
returning to work and a lack of lack of
employer accommodations
are frequent reasons for women to stop
breastfeeding before a child turns one
workplace lactation programs like the
ones contained in this bill
have been shown to increase
breastfeeding among working mothers who
are planning to breastfeed
which again benefits both the mother and
the baby
breastfeeding protects babies and
children from a host of acute
chronic diseases that has been shown to
lower health care costs for mothers and
their infants
when compared to non-breastfeeding
mothers but not only that
it also provides a real opportunity for
employers to build
loyalty trust and productivity with
their employers
employees by enabling them to provide
something so important to their child
this bill is an important initiative to
keep working mothers in the workforce
as we rebuild our economy this is
increasingly important as new hampshire
continues to experience a workforce
shortage
and women are a large and important
sector
of new hampshire's labor force women
make up almost
64 of our civilian workforce
and comprise two-thirds of the essential
workforce during the pandemic
supporting nursing mothers in the
workforce the workplace can also benefit
companies
and is part of building a modern
forward-thinking economy
you will hear from many businesses today
on that
point so i wanted to point out why this
is a very reasonable bill with a
uniquely new hampshire solution
and just highlight some points from the
broad coalition that worked on this bill
so this bill isn't about mandating
certain things it's about creating
access not mandating space the coalition
that worked on this bill was responsive
to the needs of new hampshire small
businesses and listened
to them when they expressed concerns
about
uh text in the bill which is why you'll
see
the added definition of undue hardship
we defined unto hardship
and that was at their request and you'll
see that connection of
the definition of undue hardship with
the
ability for businesses to request a
hardship exemption
we also thought it was very important to
respond to businesses
by defining what a reasonable break
period
is so you'll see that we have defined
what a reasonable break period is that
was in response
to businesses that wanted some more
clarity
and you will also note that the
definition
and you'll hear some more testimony from
doctors
is consistent with the biological needs
of a nursing woman
so if you haven't nursed before you may
not know
that nursing is uh by lactation and
nursing is a biological function
it's a give and take with mothers and
babies and so this
uh time period in um in the definition
is consistent with the biological needs
of mom and baby and again you'll hear
more about that
lastly i wanted to point out that other
state
with a similar law filling this coverage
gap
require all employers to comply but
this bill applies only to employers with
six or more employees
and that was to be consistent and thus
more predictable for businesses with new
hampshire's existing
anti-discrimination statute rsa 354-a
so i will stop there um there will be
plenty of people behind me
but i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
have we have a question representative
burroughs
yes thanks for taking my question which
is um
on the on the clause about the hardship
exemption who gets to determine
what is what is actually a hardship
exemption because it's not
spelled out yeah thank you for that
question representative burroughs and
this came up also in the senate
um we you'll hear testimony from the
department of labor but
be you'll see that this uh this bill
puts the um puts the language within
the department of labor statute so it's
clear just based where
this language will go that it's the
department of labor that will be
um interpreting it and granting those
hardship exemptions
thank you thank you okay well thank you
very much
uh then we have another senator here
uh and i've just promoted
from europe there you are
good well still good morning
we've barely made it we did
yes good morning uh mr chairman and
members of the house commerce committee
it's very nice to see you again
um i'm here to testify in support of
sb69 and i will
attempt to be brief as i know you've had
a long warning
um i'm thrilled to be here in support of
this bill i think
um you know this bill builds on the long
legacy of senator martha fuller clark
who i
am trying to step into the very large
shoes of um
but has been the result of over four
years of study by the lactation advisory
council so
you know this issue has been extensively
studied and
i think this legislation has emerged as
a very matured and sophisticated
compromise
um it's a it's a flexible bill and it
allows
accommodation by our businesses for this
very natural process
you know i think we all feel that small
businesses in new hampshire are our
lifeblood
they're our priority and it's certainly
not the intent of this bill to
to jeopardize that in any way my
personal experience is that i worked at
a company of six
or i do work at a company of six people
and they were able to accommodate
um similarly to what this bill would ask
um for me to nurse my daughter when i
had her about a year and a half ago
so i think you know senator whitley
touched on part of this
you know efforts like this support a
more modern economy for new hampshire
and if you talk to our businesses their
biggest need is employees they have open
positions
and especially now um pose pandemic you
know with the housing
market being what it is you know we need
to do everything we can as a state
to support continuing to modernize our
economy and to attract talent into the
state and so
this is just one more tool that i think
supports working families being able to
have moms return to work
and afford their housing it's such a
small
period in a woman's professional life
over the
over the overall contributions that
she'll make to her employer and so
i think that it it makes sense for us
all to support this and i hope you can
support
a recommendation of that to pass over on
the senate side we were able to see
this bill pass unanimously out of center
commerce and it also received a
unanimous floor vote so
we're hoping that house commerce will
give it the same treatment
and i appreciate the opportunity to
testify and happy to answer any
questions that i can
uh so uh representative abramson has a
question
uh thank you mr chair thank you senator
for taking my question
um how would you accommodate this
mandate
uh in uh for workers working in road
construction
workers working in what road
road construction yes so this this bill
does
ask um you know for an employer to kind
of
previously to a lot of the similar to a
lot of testimony you heard on the
previous bill
what we're trying to do here is have
employers make reasonable accommodation
so if for example
a worker could you know
return to a space that is private
somewhere it could be on or off site
you know have access to the equipment
they need which is just a chair and an
outlet
in order to express milk and then return
to the job then that would be
all we were asking and and that can be
accommodated in different ways between
the employer and the employee
[Music]
what surprise for the question you may
inquire
what about transportation i'm thinking
um
you know whether it's trucking or
you know boats or planes or what have
you what about someone working in the
field of transportation
yes sir thanks for the question and and
i would have a similar answer
um which is that you know it's just
something that the employer and the
employee need to work out but
i will point out that um you know we
make accommodations for
folks on the job for all different
things and that's required by statute
now you know the value of your employee
over the long term is
is something that needs to be considered
by the employer when you're making these
decisions and i think
acknowledging that women give birth and
that women
need to nurse their children and that
that bonding experience is good for
babies and for mothers
is one side of the coin and then i think
the other side is that it really gives
employers an opportunity to
build their relationship with their
employees i know in my case
it only increased my loyalty and
productivity with my employer because
i felt that they had really accommodated
that sort of unique period
in my in my life so i think um again
it's something
you know that isn't built into our
economy as it is but i think
is something that we should all uh start
to put the tools in place to accommodate
as it is
something that affects all of our
pregnant people across the state
if i if i may i wanted to respond to
that question too that
may give some more okay thank you i
appreciate that mr chair
um i just wanted to point out you know
we are not asking
folks and businesses to create you know
to build new spaces this is about
allowing for
and creating access rather than
mandating space
the other point i think with the
industries that you mentioned you
rightly mentioned
uh trucking construction those are our
larger businesses that already
uh are already under the current
requirement under federal law
companies of 50 employees uh or more
already are already required to do this
uh
by federal law so this is um just
thinking through what works best for our
small businesses
thank you okay
uh and then we have
uh representative abel is a co-sponsor
of the bill
yes thank you uh thank you mr chair and
thank you
colleagues um i am uh representative
richard abell
grafton uh district 13 serving lebanon
and i am a sponsor of uh
senate bill 69. um as we've heard
earlier this morning
uh uh this bill has
uh has come before that the uh
before house commerce committee
uh in the past this is how i learned
about it
and came to support it um
it has passed this committee uh
in prior sessions and has been
uh and has also passed uh in in
other versions of the bill uh through
uh through the
house at large
i sponsored senate bill 69 because
of three things i strongly believe it's
pro-business
believe it is a pro-employee
and i believe it's pro-family and i'm
just
not going to talk about the bill i'm
going to talk about why i support it
um although i'll answer i'd be happy to
answer questions
and i will uh send the
the the clerk a copy of my written
testimony
this bill helps is pro business
because it helps businesses recruit and
retain
quality employees quality employees
in an important demographic it builds
loyalty in employees who appreciate
their
employers reasonable accommodations
and uh as was mentioned just
prior um i think it can also
uh increase uh an employee's
productivity and attachment
to the success of the business that's
important
it also reduces the time and the cost of
employee turnover
and i've run two businesses and i can
tell you that that's one of the things
that is always a problem for a business
um because it helps retain employees
uh and it doesn't put you in a situation
where you need to find and train
replacements i find this to be a
win-win-win
as working mothers are able to stay with
their
employer and
i urge my uh commerce
colleagues in your wisdom to give
a favorable response of ought to pass
to senate bill 69
so employers uh
employees families and our our
economy can all benefit and thank you
that
and i'm happy to answer questions
uh i don't see any
questions so thank you very much okay uh
well now uh switch gears a little bit
and we have the department of health and
human services
lisa stewart
good morning
and members of the committee you can
hear me correct yes we can
okay my name is lisa sirois i'm a
registered dietitian
and a lactation consultant and i've been
working with breastfeeding families for
the past 20 years
i'm here to speak today on behalf of the
new hampshire department of health and
human services
as a long-time public health
professional in the division of public
health
the department of health and human
services supports breastfeeding mothers
and
infants through its many public health
programs
those programs include the wic nutrition
program breastfeeding care counselor
chronic disease programs maternal and
child health programs
such as our home visiting program
prenatal
primary care and child health programs
all of the aforementioned programs
contribute to the support protection
and promotion of breastfeeding for new
hampshire families
i'd like to share most recently the
division of public health
awarded a three-year grant to two keene
state college professors
to implement a workplace lactation
support initiative
the project funded the creation of 43
new lactation spaces
across all of new hampshire through
competitive mini grants
to small and medium-sized new hampshire
businesses
the mini grants included funds to
establish a private space
on-site technical assistance with
writing a policy
in training for their human resource
staff
through this project more than 3 500
working women of child bearing age now
have access to a clean and private space
to express milk at work
in a policy that allows for reasonable
break time through this project
employers were also offered access to a
free online training module
and an employer toolkit to help with
establishing
in sustaining a comprehensive program
both of these resources are available
for free
for all new hampshire employers and are
on the department's website now
the health effects of breastfeeding are
well recognized in the united states
as previously mentioned one of the most
highly effective preventative measures a
mother can take to protect the health of
her infant and herself
is to breastfeed greater than 88 percent
of new hampshire women initiate
breastfeeding after delivery in the
hospital
but less than 40 percent continue to
breastfeed through the first
year as recommended by the american
academy of pediatrics
among women of low income in new
hampshire
only 72 percent ever breastfeed
and less than 20 percent continue
through the first year
returning to work is one of the reasons
cited by working moms for stopping
breastfeeding before reaching their
goals
i thank you for the opportunity to share
some of the work that the department has
been doing over the past couple years
i submitted my testimony in writing and
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you thank you uh
[Music]
i don't see any questions so thank you
very much
um okay so next uh
somebody raised their hand uh
uh i i rudolph i i don't see you on my
list here so i'm gonna
i'll i'll have to wait a little bit for
you here uh
so next up is donna hosper
and donna you just have to
unmute yourself
good morning good morning afternoon oh
that's right
i started in the morning as did you this
has been a long day for you guys i
really appreciate the opportunity to
speak before you
uh chairman hunt and the the other
members of your committee
um my name again donna gaudette hosmer
i'm the mother of
four teenagers all of whom were
breastfed
i'm also a business owner in that until
very recently
my family and i had owned auto serve
dealerships in tilton new hampshire
we'd own that business for over 30 years
and i'm also a partner
in a growing manufacturing plant in
lancaster
so between these two businesses we
employed well over 300
people i'm speaking in strong support of
senate bill 69
a bill designed to provide mothers
returning to work with sufficient space
and a reasonable break to express milk
as has been said current breastfeeding
legislation put forth by the affordable
care act only covers hourly employees
leaving a gap of one in four women new
hampshire is the only state in
new england without its own workplace
breastfeeding legislation
so sp 69 would require employers to
accommodate reasonable time and space
for nursing moms to express work during
the work day
or to express milk during the work day
this is important because this
legislation has
as has been said supports mothers but
also families as their dynamics change
and women transition back to work
as a business owner and an industry
leader i
am sensitive to mandates that are often
well intentioned
but ultimately unnecessarily inhibit
small business
and i believe that the legislature
should exercise
great discretion when considering
mandates
and only do so when there's a compelling
overriding consideration
sb69 is an opportunity to pass
legislation
that supports women returning to work
supports the healthiest
option for children and puts new
hampshire on par
with other new england states who've
already recognized the importance of
this
issue i jumped at the chance to champion
initiative when my friend joyce kelly
who's chairing the new hampshire
breastfeeding task force invited me to
speak to your committee today
in fact our dealership participated in
that mini grant program that lisa sirois
had just spoken about
a couple of years ago and i attached to
my testimony which i submitted
a flyer of the lactation space that we
created
in our business we um were very proud of
the space that we
created we posted those flyers
throughout our business
and we encouraged the widespread use of
the lactation lounge
as we called it um among not only our
employees
but our customers and as someone
mentioned
earlier the um the response was not only
positive
we did see um the the returning loyalty
and um increased productivity because
our our people knew we we were genuinely
invested in them
and and i see as a business owner the
how that helps with
turnover which can be very costly
this initiative resonates with me also
as a working mom
who nursed and because it's not only
consistent with our corporate
culture to be family friendly we were
always looking for ways to empower women
but something joyce kelly had said to me
early on really stuck
she said when women encounter barriers
to nursing at work
it's more likely they'll give up and
instinctively i knew that this was true
because i too struggled a lot with
nursing but fortunately for
me i didn't have to face obstacles at
work or from a supervisor who didn't
understand
i'm grateful for the people who
encouraged me and helped me achieve
some modicum of success in my nursing
and i want all mothers to feel like they
can do this
and not give up on nursing or working
giving up because of work pressures can
be very painful for mothers
who only wish to give their children the
best possible start
it can even discourage women from
returning to work and that's not good
for our economy
and i wouldn't have been able to nurse
my children if obstacles were in my way
instead of encouragement and support
so eliminating workplace barriers will
contribute to
a mother's success here and have a great
positive
impact on new hampshire families and
businesses
in closing sp 69 provides the necessary
support for nursing mothers in the
workplace
and fosters the growth of healthy
families throughout new hampshire
and business growth as more mothers
return to work
knowing that they can nurse and work for
these
reasons i'm asking for your support
of sb69 and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you
uh representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
the question this is more philosophical
um if employers benefit from reduced
retention
and keeping better workers and tracking
better workers
uh why have the state mandated if
employers are already doing this as much
as they practically can
why have the state step in and force
them to do it even more
um i don't i don't know that they all
see the forest through the trees
um i think that my personal experience
has been that by making this investment
which sometimes seems hard at first when
you're looking at
change i've i've seen i've reaped the
benefits of those decisions
and so i'm speaking from my perspective
i know
that it increased our retention it
decreased
turnover we had happier when we sold
our business a couple of months ago
about a third of our business our
employees worked for us for over 20
years
we were just a family that cared and
people stayed with us so i
mean i think it's a great investment and
i know is it coming from an industry
that was primarily male dominated
we had a huge and growing um infusion of
women over the last 10 years in our
industry so
that was my experience i think if if you
invest in them they will come and they
will stay
okay thank you uh
okay since you mentioned her i guess
we'll i'll call up joyce
kelly and
joyce if you want to raise your hand
because i don't see you
right off oh you must be the breast
task force ah see that's why i didn't
see you okay
went in by title rather than name
can you hear me yes we can okay i'll
start my video
thanks donna for that uh good morning
chairman hunt and committee members
uh my name is joyce kelly i am a
resident of laconia new hampshire
a registered nurse and the chair of the
new hampshire breastfeeding task force
the new hampshire breastfeeding task
force is an educational nonprofit
and is the recognized state
breastfeeding coalition of the united
states breastfeeding committee our
mission is to promote
protect and support breastfeeding
through education
outreach and advocacy breastfeeding is
regarded by all major health
organizations as the optimal
infant feeding method that supports
improved health outcomes
we have approximately 15 members
throughout the state many of whom work
in hospital settings but also community
settings
public health settings and educators
senate bill 69 closes the gap that was
unintentionally left
by the federal breakdown for nursing
mother laws passed in 2010
that required employers to provide
access to time and space for breast milk
expression during the work day
to hourly workers covered by the fair
labor standards act
so often we see questions raised about
this in
in in the testimony which we have today
many of the workers conditions raised
are already covered by the federal law
but this senate bill 69 would require
employers to provide access to time and
space
to express milk during the workday for
all workers regardless of labor category
with the exceptions noted in the bill
that um senator whitley had also
mentioned
and this would include teachers who were
excluded from federal protection so
currently teachers
do not have access to time and space to
express milk during the workday
senate bill 69 is the result of several
years collaboration
and work of the governor's advisory
council lactation of which we were a
part of
we have collaborated with groups
including the department of labor as
well as the new hampshire business and
industry association
in order to craft a bill that we feel
addresses the relevant needs related to
workplace breastfeeding support
that is comprehensive and a value to
both employers and employees
as stated new hampshire is the only
state in new england that does not have
a state level law
to protect working mothers new hampshire
senate bill 69 is a very reasonable bill
that proposes accommodations for one
year after the birth of a child for an
employee to have access to time and
space
to pump during the workday other states
such as maine and vermont have laws that
are much more extensive including up to
three years of protection
we feel that the bill as drafted is a
new hampshire solution for working
mothers and employees
we did choose to define reasonable break
time for approximately 30 minutes every
three hours in a work day
because one it is physiologically what
most women need to maintain their milk
supply when
expressing milk went away from their
baby and two because we have received
many
inquiries over the years from new
hampshire businesses and hr
professionals
asking what is reasonable for a new mom
to express milk during a workday because
they just
don't know please note that the bill
does include language that
allows an employer and an employee to
agree to agree to different terms
and while we have chosen to define
reasonable break time there is
variability from mother to mother
in case the case often based on the age
of the infant
with the need for milk expression often
becoming less over time as the baby gets
older
and mind you it is just for the one year
it is important to note that this bill
does not necessarily require an employer
to undertake the construction
or building of a room solely for the
purposes of milk expression
this bill provides for access to time
and space to pump
it may be temporary or maybe a permanent
space but even when an employer chooses
to make a permanent space it can often
be completed at a nominal cost i was
one of the consultants on the mini
grants and we saw quite the variety of
spaces we have resources available to
help people do that
this bill makes sense it would benefit
employers with
improved worker retention and
satisfaction and it has been
recently established that there's
approximately a three to one return on
investment
for employers who have established a
workplace breastfeeding program for
their employees
this bill has bipartisan support and i
encourage you to vote ought to pass
on this bill as it is thanks very much
for allowing me to testify today
okay thank you uh we do have a question
representative emman
i assume he's going to ask you for a
copy of your testimony
i did send it to the um committee okay
keith you have a question
what was that ammon can you hear me
i don't know he may he must be looking
for it
i'm i'm right here now okay third time's
the try
uh if you haven't already could you
submit written testimony
to the committee yeah i did submit it to
the committee
email the general email with along with
um letters
of support that were sent into the task
force okay thank you i'll look for it
sure okay
great uh we thank you very much for your
testimony i don't see
any other questions from the committee
members okay
uh so then still going along
uh hillary schuler oh i see you hillary
so don't raise your hand
okay i'm just promoting you hillary
and all you have to do is unmute
yourself
hello good afternoon good afternoon
my name is hilary schuler i'm from
enfield new hampshire and i'm a nursing
working mom to two young boys
one of them i have with me thank you for
the opportunity to testify today
when i returned to work after having my
first son in 2019
i was not ready i was not prepared for
the stress that came with figuring out
my new normal
how to get out of the house with a baby
in tow how it would feel dropping him
off at daycare while i headed to work
for eight hours
i heard i would have to advocate for
myself and for my son
because i had a shared office i needed a
separate space to express milk while at
work
i had had a conversation with my manager
prior to my return
and i was told they had a space for me
to use that space was a storage closet
it was hot the door didn't lock and it
wasn't private
i knew this space wasn't adequate it
wasn't sanitary
but i was told it was all there was
after a couple of weeks sweating in this
storage closet as i expressed the food
to feed my child
i knew i needed to advocate for myself
because if i didn't this is what i was
what i would be stuck with i reached out
to human resources
and my employer and i explained the
situation it took a few weeks but a new
space was found
an empty office two floors up i felt
like i had won the lottery
my job required me to attend events and
conferences outside of my office
anytime i would attend an event or
conference i would reach out to the
organizers and let them know that i'm a
mom
and i asked about a lactation space when
i asked about a lactation space i was
often met with looks of annoyance
and disgust and was told there was no
space for me
i have expressed milk in numerous public
bathrooms hoping that the power cord to
my pump would reach the only outlet
available
i have expressed milk in my car in the
middle of winter to avoid having to pump
in a bathroom again
and i have expressed milk in a storage
closet behind a bar at a conference
venue
yes i have learned how to advocate for
myself and my child during our
breastfeeding journey
but lactation spaces should be the norm
not the exception
there is enough stress put on the
shoulders of mothers and working mothers
where and when she can express milk to
feed her child should not be the cause
of any
stress i fully support this bill as a
working mother and a native to the state
of new hampshire
thank you again for the opportunity and
time to testify this morning
thank you very much
uh okay i guess people are getting
hungry
all right uh let the fireworks begin
so uh kate frederick
and uh welcome back kate
thank you i hope there won't be any
fireworks
um i would like it if we could all work
together
and that's what my intention is i do
support
breastfeeding rights um let me
fill some most of you heard me in the
last hearing i just want to fill in some
gaps
i founded the new hampshire
breastfeeding rights coalition
we're the largest coalition in new
hampshire and we're the most inclusive
coalition um
i as i mentioned before i'm a law school
student
and a student of public health um and i
had
been fired for requesting accommodations
to breastfeed during work hours when i
was employed by the state of new
hampshire
as a child support officer
i've had legal proceedings
in this conflict going on for nine years
without any resolution
my case is still active there was
recently a tie
in the new hampshire supreme court
over whether or not i have the right to
sue not
whether there was any discrimination or
not and because there was a tie
by default i lost there's been new
motions filed
um so the case is not over yet um what
i'd like to talk to you about today
is obviously this bill um i don't think
it's
constitutional which is why i'm opposing
it
and i want to point out some of the
flaws
and problems with this bill but i want
to do it very briefly
so similar to lat the last hearing
i submitted my report my testimony
on page three i just want to refer you
to
rsa 275 37a
smokers rights there's actually
statutory protection
against discriminating against employees
who smoke
but there is not any statutory
protection against
employees who are lactating
this bill is a pumping only bill and it
specifically states that expressing milk
excludes breastfeeding
so let me explain to you the result of
that
what what you're going to have is what
happened to me is i
i requested privacy to breastfeed
during work hours because my son was not
able to drink from a bottle yet
as an infant and i was told i had to
breastfeed in a public
space either in front of my clients my
co-workers
or outside in the parking lot or sitting
on the stairwell
in an office building with multiple
offices so
if i had been willing to expose my
breasts and my
baby
and be naked from the top up
potentially i suppose i would have kept
my job
but i wasn't willing to do that to keep
my job i wanted privacy
to breastfeed
recently the new hampshire legislature
and i commend them
passed a bill making it illegal to
discriminate against someone for their
gender
including transgender well guess what
folks
transgender people can breastfeed they
can also
chest feed and what you're gonna create
here
is forcing people forcing employees
to feed their babies directly in public
and many of them may not want to many of
them may want
privacy like i did there's also the
issue of safety
so this bill leaves out
break time for breastfeeding or chest
feeding and
space private safe space
for breastfeeding or chest feeding
um i'd like to also explain
this may seem very basic to some of you
but
what is a nursing mother
is it a breastfeeding mother is it a
pumping mother
is it chest feeding person is
it an employee who's lactating and
their baby died at childbirth but
they're pumping so that they can donate
milk
to a milk bank typically
a nursing mother can be all of these
you may pump you may breastfeed
etc at different times depending on
different situations
i support a bill that provides
an incremental bit of success i don't
think this bill does
i think this bill is going backwards
which is why i'm opposing it
you know priest for governor sununu i
have to say
i'm a fan he
implemented the executive order
[Music]
allowing state employees like i was
to bring their babies to work to
breastfeed them during work hours
because he values the importance of
breastfeeding
this this bill is going backwards
because instead of codifying the
executive order
into statute it's excluding
breastfeeding
so in order to be brief
i will leave my comment
with one more point there's currently a
federal law i'm sorry a federal bill
that is looking to accomplish something
very similar
the legislature could wait and see what
happens with the federal bill
it's called providing urgent maternal
protections
in the nursing mothers act lastly
i think that the state of new hampshire
spends
a lot of money on supporting
breastfeeding
i don't see how you can support
breastfeeding by excluding breastfeeding
or firing someone for breastfeeding or
needing to breastfeed
and i don't feel that an employee
should have to negotiate to keep her
career and her baby alive
it just doesn't seem like the new
hampshire way to me
thank you thank you
representative abramson has a question
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
this bill as
written it's your concern
in your testimony that that the
unknown cost of this or the problems of
this bill can make it more difficult
for employers to hire nursing mothers
for nursing mothers to find work
i apologize let me tell you if what i
heard is what you said
you're asking me if my our concerns are
about financial needs or about
access to work for the uh for the
employers facing the cost of this
this uh unfunded mandate is it is it
going to make it more difficult for
employers to employ nursing mothers
and could it make it more difficult for
nursing mothers to find work in the
workplace
i see you know similar to
your question in the last hearing
unfortunately the answer is
possibly probably with some exception
a few employers may take advantage and
illegally discriminate but i believe
that most employers want
to do the right thing but the problem is
employers need
certainty right they need to know what's
going to happen when
how long is it going to take how much
money is it going to take
and how will that affect everything else
and so
when you have pregnancy or you're
lactating you don't always have those
answers on hand
and it also fluctuates
it's sort of like a moving target so
that's the conflict is the employees
can't always give the employer the
certainty that they need to feel
confident confident and comfortable and
plan ahead
so what the federal bills have done and
what
maine vermont and massachusetts have
done
all the states that are adjacent to new
hampshire
they've found a way to allow
breastfeeding during work hours
and they have a provision that says um
the employee is allowed to breastfeed
anywhere
they are authorized to be or anywhere
they and their child
are authorized to be so breastfeeding
accommodations
don't cause anything if you're willing
to breastfeed in public
if you need to create a space i think
probably senator whitley or maybe it was
joyce kelly said that this is just a
temporary structure nobody's
being told to create a brand new office
um you could even use a pop-up tent
so i can share with you um
a website that breaks down
how to create a space in any industry
i'll email you the website but it's on
women's health dot gov
slash supporting nursing moms
etc i'll send it to you right now so you
can see it and it breaks it down by
restaurants hotels
retail road construction
etc so i hope that answers your question
okay uh we have another question
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i'd like to see
where
um in this bill you're saying that
breastfeeding is excluded
because what i see it is has to do with
um the employer
needing to make a accommodation for
pumping
it does i don't see where it excludes
breastfeeding
definition of expressing milk so this
still defines expressing milk
as excluding breastfeeding i don't i
don't see where it says excluding
breastfeeding this shall not include
breastfeeding i believe i
i can find it exactly for you if you
want okay would you find that please
it's uh
roman numeral three expression of milk
means the initiation of lactation by
manual or mechanical means but shall not
include
breastfeeding but that's just a
definition of expression of milk
that doesn't say you can't breastfeed it
shall not include breastfeeding so
employ employers do not have to provide
accommodations for breastfeeding this
bill
says you have to provide accommodations
for expression of milk shall not include
breastfeeding
so what representative bartlett what i
was told by
the state of new hampshire was the
lactation room was only for pumping
no breastfeeding allowed in the
lactation room there's a
the federal law is the nursing mother's
provision
it amended the fair labor standards act
in the affordable care act
and it used the terms express milk
so it doesn't include breastfeeding i'm
sorry i have to disagree i don't see
that in that
in the bill would you believe
okay uh are there any other
questions seeing none we thank you again
it's
always a pleasure seeing you again all
right
so having no other person now we'll have
the last the light
uh miss malachi you now have the last
word
assuming you're still there
i am here thank you
thank you very much um so
there's been a plethora of testimony on
the previous bill
and some of those those items certainly
are still standing um as we're in a
in pretty much the same topic i wanted
to
again say thank you to representative
hunt and to the rest of the committee
for allowing me to give a few moments of
testimony here
and i would certainly like to expressly
thank senator whitley senator perkins
culka
lisa sirois and joyce kelly from the new
hampshire breastfeeding task force
for all of the work and and their
testimony that's been given
although sb 69 does not directly affect
the commission the human rights
commission
had two members on the
um on the lactation council which worked
collaboratively
to put this bill together and i believe
senator whitley stated that this bill
was something that was
moving through the process the
legislative process last cycle
but as so many things got laid on the
table
due to covid this was one of them and
the commission would certainly like to
express their support
for sb69 for it to pass as written
for their there are no additional
amendments or changes
that need to be made and
mothers and families have had to wait
especially mothers in the workplace and
and businesses have had to wait uh quite
a while for this so it would be
um wonderful if the committee would
vote this as ought to pass and move it
along
i know that there was at least a a a
question relative to
accommodation and um and i also
appreciate representative bartlett's
understanding
um when i re-read that section it looks
as though you were
correct in that that that was part of
the definition and not expressly
um moving removing breastfeeding um and
again
when you talk about reasonable
accommodations
um and i don't remember the woman's name
that testified earlier that has a
cart that had the family car dealership
if
in that conversation um and i
happened to have my child nearby i mean
uh and that would have to be something
that you would have to discuss
because the average woman that's working
may not be one that is currently
breastfeeding
during her work shift right so when i go
home
i may do that with my child and i
primarily would need a place
for expression of milk now if my
employer
says hey i don't mind someone dropping
off your child and you can nurse your
child
during the same amount of time where i
would normally
do my milk expression great that's
between
the woman and her employer and that
could be considered
as we've talked before a reasonable
accommodation
what might not be reasonable is if the
employee is requesting during their
eight hour shift
to leave the office or the place of work
multiple times to go to a place where
the child is located
to then nurse the child and come back
that may not be reasonable and that
would but that would again be a
conversation
that the employee and the employer would
have if the employer allows that person
to make up work because that's okay and
they would have
maybe two hours out of their eight hour
day in order to do that
that's great but this bill doesn't
change the flexibility
that an employee and an employer would
have to work together
it simply allows there to be a clean
safe and private place for this
lactation process
to take place so i thank you all for
allowing me to come again before you and
testify
i'm certainly available for any
questions but i'm sure you're ready to
have lunch
thank you
oh thank you i i screwed up again
uh uh i'm sorry courtney uh i
he wanted to testify all right sorry
he's can't read the small print or
something today
okay thank you very much malakai uh so
courtney tanner uh also would like to
did sign up
so absolutely i know we will be brief is
brief
um thank you chairman hunt and members
of the committee i'm going to testify
today in two capacities
first as the director of government
relations at dartmouth hitchcock
darvish hitchcock support senate bill 69
is drafted
in your email you'll find written
testimony from dr maria padin who's our
chief medical officer
at our community group practices located
in concord manchester nashua
dr perdina is a trained and practicing
obg phys
ob gyn physician and highlighted the
benefits
of breastfeeding and expressed milk to
mothers and babies
just to highlight very briefly for
infants the protection of infectious
diseases
and sids for mothers the lower risk of
breast
ovarian cancer diabetes hypertension
just to name a few
dr perdin noted that senate bill 69
provides a minimal standard for
employers to support their nursing
employees
but second i'd like to testify as a
working mother to a nurse
to a daughter who i nursed i live in
bedford new hampshire with my husband my
19 month old daughter and our nutty
border collie
i'm a full-time employee at dartmouth
hitchcock i'm actually as i
stated as a lobbyist and
eager to get back into the committee
room with you all
joanna my daughter struggled to latch
when she was born
after a stressful first week of life
filled with doctors appointments and
unwelcomed weight loss we took joanna to
a pediatric dentist and
revised her tongue ties and for the next
six weeks joanna and i with
the fierce support of my husband worked
hard to get joanna to
improve her ability to latch we took her
to many
ot appointments and the pediatricians a
number of times we worked with a
lactation consultant
and by the time joanna was eight weeks
old she had it down and then
four weeks later i had to return to work
the transition was hard but it was
possible because my employer made it
very clear that
my family came first and my work came
second
um similar to all of your days at the
state house here you are going well into
your lunch period my days were
unpredictable
but my employer made it very clear that
i should need to find some time to
express milk down in that mama roo in
the basement
i will just close up by saying in return
what i
am able to give to my employer is i've
never had to call
out of stick from work my little one has
never been sick she's 19 months old and
i'm
knocking on wood as i say that she's
never had a sore throat and ear
infection or a sniffle
um as a working mom i'm asking you to
pass senate bill 69 as drafted
it sends a signal to young families like
mine that new hampshire cares about them
i'm happy to take questions
representative hump and i'm also happy
happy to have you all go to lunch
hey thank you uh i don't
see any hands and anyone have any
questions i think
i think we're all set thank you very
much thank you uh
seeing no more hands up either
on the attendee side so i guess i really
did get everybody this time
few weeks okay so uh the senate bill 69
had 130 supporters
eight people were opposed and two were
neutral and with that i will close the
public hearing on senate bill 69
and that is our day for today
so for the committee members uh i'm not
going to do anything for next tuesday
because i assume there might be some
caucuses or some other
things that will get us ready